Daniel Schnellerman, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Oui. Alors, je suis
journaliste euh je suis fondateur,
animateur, directeur de la publication
du site Arrêt sur image et le site arrêt
sur image prolonge l'émission euh Arrêt
sur image qui a été diffusée sur France
5 entre 95 et 2007 et qui a été euh
supprimé assez brutalement de la grille
en 2007. Certains se s'en souviennent
peut-être. Ouais. Alors, par ailleurs,
je suis euh je fais une chronique tous
les lundis dans Libération euh qui
elle-même succède à une chronique que je
faisais dans le journal de Le Monde dont
j'ai été licencié euh là c'était en 2003
euh et j'ai commencé ma ma carrière de
journaliste au monde en 79.
Ça nous rajunit pas tout ça.
Ça nous rajunit pas. Je suis vraiment
désolé hein.
Ça fait 30 Je suis vraiment désolé de de
faire de faire le vieux.
39 ans ?
Ouais. Euh je sais pas. 39 ans depuis
c'est bien calculé ou
ouais ça ça va vite hein
ça va vite.
Euh virer du monde. Pourquoi
alors virer du monde ? Parce que parce
que la la critique média c'est
compliqué.
Pourquoi c'est compliqué ?
Bah parce que en fait ma ma ma
spécialité c'est de c'est de faire de la
critique média dans les médias. Donc
c'est ce que je faisais au monde où
j'avais une une chronique d'abord
quotidienne puis ensuite hebdomadaire
qui était une chronique de réflexion sur
les médias. Enfin le les mêmes trucs que
je fais encore aujourd'hui. Et quand il
s'est trouvé que le monde lui-même euh a
été au centre d'une polémique puisque il
y avait un bouquin qui avait été publié
en 2003, il s'appelait La face cachée du
monde. Je sais pas si on se tuto ou on
se voit.
On se tutoi.
On se tutoie.
Donc je sais pas si tu t'en souviens euh
on expliquera pourquoi on se tuto après.
Ah je sais pas. Bah alors tu expliqueras
parce que moi je le sais pas en fait le
D'accord. le donc un bouquin extrêmement
critique sur le sur le monde et j'en
avais rendu compte dans ma dans ma
chronique, ça n'a pas plu la direction
de l'époque donc Jean-Marie Jean-Marie
Colombie, Edou Penel et Alain Mac
euh et donc j'étais viré. Mais tu étais
au courant de tout ça ? Non.
Ouais ouais. On a bossé on a bossé
depuis 48 heures sur ton dossier. Ah
très bien.
On a appelé des copains journalistes,
ils m'ont dit "Oh tu vas recevoir le
fouille, merde !"
Ouais mais c'est flatteur. C'est
flatteur, non ?
C'est flatteur
non ? Si si complètement. Et euh on va
expliquer pourquoi on se tu toi. On
s'est vu il y a combien de temps ? Il y
a 2 ans. Parce que tu cherchais mon
numéro de téléphone. Tu as contacté un
journaliste d'investigation pour l'avir
de le journaliste en question Denis
Robert qui t'a gentiment dit d'aller te
tu l'aurais pas et et ensuite on on
allait te voir sur internet et puis
ou comme je suis assistant comme garçon
je je t'ai finalement trouvé.
Non c'est moi qui t'ai trouvé et c'est
moi qui t'ai donné rendez-vous.
Tu savais je te cherchais.
Ouais ouais. Puis tu avais peur qu'on se
fâchait un peu derrière.
Euh,
j'avais pas peur de grand-chose.
Après, tu as peut-être un pouvoir de
nuisance qui m'échappe si tu veux. Mais
ouais, ouais. Bon, on va on peut être
casse-couill aussi mais on est jamais
casse-couille. On est gentil. Et donc,
tu fais la critique des médias.
Attends, non, mais faut raconter où on
s'est rencontré parce que c'est drôle.
Je Bah ouais, je t'ai dit je t'ai pas
l'endroit exact mais
je t'ai dit viens on va faire du sport.
Ouais, voilà.
Voilà. Et tu es venu habillé en dimanché
et tu m'as dit "Non, le sport c'est pas
trop pour moi."
Ah c'est pas du tout mon souvenir. Mon
souvenir c'est qu'on s'est retrouvé dans
un grand parc de la banlieue ouest
parisienne. Ça va comme ça ?
Ça va
ça va.
Ouais.
Il faisait beau
et qu'on a fait des qu'on a fait des
tours de parc. J'avais l'impression
d'être Woodward et Bernstein en une
seule personne et de rencontrer Gorge
Profonde. Mais sauf que si tu veux, tu
m'as rien dit. Donc
voilà.
Donc j'ai fait le déplacement pour rien.
Exactement. Et donc le le à la suite de
ça, on s'est intéressé un peu à Rest sur
Image. D'ailleurs, on était très fan du
temps où c'était euh sur France 5. C'est
ça.
C'est ça.
Euh on avait été tous euh très attristés
de de voir cette émission euh
disparaître, vaporiser. Le motif,
c'était aussi la critique des médias. Ça
fait la le motif, c'est la même chose.
C'est-à-dire que on était France 5
faisait à l'époque fait toujours partie
du groupe France Télévision.
Euh et donc bah en fait le le la
surprise c'est pas qu'on a été viré en
2007, la surprise c'est qu'on est tenu
si longtemps puisque l'émission a
commencé en 95. 2007 ça fait 12 ans.
Finalement le truc étonnant c'est qu'on
ait pu tenir 12 ans en étant cette
espèce de d'ovni à l'intérieur de la
télévision.
Alors, c'était compliqué parce que en 12
ans, il y a eu plusieurs présidents
successifs de France Télévision qui sont
qui sont succédés. Euh et un nouveau le
le nouveau président de France
Télévision quand il arrivait en fait, il
avait il avait deux voix. Il avait la
voix de l'intérieur, c'estàdire les
journalistes de France Télé, du 20h, de
France 2 et cetera qui lui disaient
"Mais quand est-ce que tu vires ces ces
ces ces emmerdeurs et cetera ?" Mais en
même temps, comme c'était France 5, il
avait aussi la voix des enseignants, des
profs euh qui rencontraient ce que
c'était à l'époque la la chaîne de
savoir et de la connaissance. Et les
profs eux, il disaient formidable, arrê
sur image, c'est l'émission qu'on
attendait depuis toujours qui enfin
ceci, cela machin. Et donc finalement
euh finalement peénard peénard, sauf que
un jour il y en a eu un un peu plus obtu
que les autres qui s'appelait Patrick de
Carolis. Et alors Patrick de Carolis euh
donc qui est devenu président de France
Télé et quelques années avant, il
s'occupait d'une émission de France 3
qui s'appelait Desracin et des ailes et
euh il avait bidonné une émission,
c'est-à-dire qu'il avait fait passer
dans son émission un faux sauvetage en
montagne pour un vrai sauvetage et c'est
nous qui avions révélé le bidonnage.
Alors après 2 ans après quand le gars il
devient président de France télé euh
voilà
rappelé de toi quoi. et s'est rappelé
et tu as sauté.
Et voilà. C'est chronique un petit peu
ça dans le monde journalistique
quoi. Dans
de faire sauter les gens qu'on aime pas
trop.
Euh en général
ceux qui fouillent un peu trop.
Ouais, en général on se débrouille
plutôt pour les les placards d'isé.
C'est-à-dire, on se débrouille plutôt
pour les muter ailleurs, pour les Alors,
ça à la télévision, c'est ce qui se fait
beaucoup à la télévision, les les gens
dont on veut se débarrasser, on leur on
leur file un titre à trois lignes, euh
on les met dans un bureau et on les
oublie à la télévision publique. Euh il
y a pas tellement de journalistes virés.
Non mais c'est vrai, je sais pas dans
les dans les dernières années des
journalistes virés des grands médias euh
alors au de lancelin que tu as reçu a
été viré du Nouvels, voilà. Mais euh à
part ça, il y en a pas il y en a pas des
masses. Ça se en général ça se passe
d'une manière plus on va dire plus soft.
Bon, tu as écrit un petit bouquin
[raclement de gorge]
Berlin 1933.
Pourquoi n'ont-ils rien dit ?
Ça raconte quoi ? [__] elles sont
hardes les questions ici. [rires]
Fais pas le malin.
Non non non, je je salue. Je je salue
les questions. Euh qu'est-ce que ça
raconte ? Ça raconte le la manière dont
dont Hitler et les nazis ont été
couverts par euh la presse
internationale, c'est-à-dire la presse
des des des futures démocraties, les les
Français, les Britanniques, les
Américains. Euh à partir du moment où
ils sont arrivés au pouvoir,
c'est-à-dire en 33. Parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir, c'est qu'en 33 quand quand
Hitler arrive, il y a 200 journalistes
occidentaux qui sont correspondants à
Berlin pour des journaux le New York
Times, le Daily Mail, à l'époque c'était
Paris soir, il y avait quelques journaux
qui existaient à l'époque qui existait
encore, le Figaro, la Croix, l'UA et
cetera. Donc ils sont 200. Ils sont
habitués à couvrir l'Allemagne, ils ont
couvert les gouvernements précédents,
ils sont habitués à travailler à peu
près normalement. Et puis coup arrive
cette espèce de de de d'ovni politique,
le le nazisme avec Hitler et comment des
journalistes normaux
calibrés pour une période normale, pour
un régime politique normal vont arriver
euh ou ne vont pas arriver plutôt
puisque en fait c'est ça le sujet du
bouquin euh à raconter ce qu'il voit.
Donc il faut raconter un peu plus en
détail. Il se donne des
Non mais j'attends des questions. C'est
chiant je je compte un peu sur un
échange.
Non mais l'échange il viendra après.
Ah il viendra après. D'accord.
Là on pose les bases. [rires]
Parfait.
On fait on fait l'anaconda.
Donc là tuattends des tunnels en fait.
Non non non non non. tu vas voir, tu vas
voir à quelle sauce tu vas être mangé. E
euh donc le bouquin, t'expliques, ils se
retrouvent tous dans un bar où ils se
retrouvent tous, ils discutent, ils se
racontent leurs petites histoires et il
y a une autocensure gravissime.
Après l'histoire, l'histoire absus, ceux
qui ont pris position contre ce qui se
passait dans cet asile de fou,
raconte-nous un petit peu.
Non, mais ce qu'il faut raconter, je
pense hein, c'est c'est comment j'ai eu
l'idée de ce livre ? Non, ça c'est la
question, ça va venir vole pas les
questions, laisse des déployés.
Alors donc la question c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe de dans
l'Allemagne de 33 ? Les journalistes ils
se retrouvent à combien ? Ils
s'échangent des informations ils sont
ils sont 200
ou ils sont 200. Ils sont il ils
côtoient le monde politique pour être
sous le robinet de l'information et ils
refusent de marquer ce qu'il voit
clairement ou ils sont born ils se font
de l'autocenture ils font mais alors
c'est c'est plus compliqué que ça si tu
veux. Le En général c'est des gens qui
sont en Allemagne depuis longtemps.
C'est des gens qui aiment l'Allemagne,
qui sont germanophones,
le seul plusvalue d'ailleurs.
C'est Ouais. Parce que je veux dire en
général, ils sont sur le poste de Berlin
parce que il parlent allemand. Il y a
pas tellement de journalistes qui
parlent allemand ni aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs, ni encore à l'époque. Donc
les voilà, c'est leur plusvalue, c'est
qu'il parle allemand. Euh et donc ils
veulent pas être ils veulent pas être
expulsés. Mais mets ton micro droit
Alors,
voilà.
Oui,
impeccable. Ouais, c'est bon les gars.
Ça va ?
Pourquoi il y en a qu'un seul ?
Parce qu'il paraît qu'on peut pas en
mettre deux sur le col de chemise.
Impeccable. Bon, est-ce que au niveau du
son, c'est bon ? C'est bon.
Bon et
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
quand les nazis arrivent, il y a un
journaliste qui va être expulsé très
vite
parce que il raconte ce qu'il voit. Pas
de l'humanité. Non, un mec du c'est un
américain, c'est un journaliste du
Chicago Daily News euh qui s'appelle
Edgar Hansel Morer, faut je crois qu'il
faut il faut donner son nom parce que
c'est c'est important. euh et qui depuis
avant Hitler d'ailleurs parce que le le
en fait l'antisémitisme en Allemagne
monte de depuis des années sous la
République de Veillear avant Hitler, il
a il a fait les articles et il a fait un
livre explique montrant et racontant
avec des détails la montée de
l'antisémitisme.
Il a écrit que l'Allemagne était en
train de devenir un asile de fou. Donc
Hitler prend le pouvoir en janvier 33 et
euh 8 mois plus tard, en septembre euh
il est expulsé sur pression des nazis.
et l'ambassadeur américain cède. Et à
partir de ce moment-là, c'est vrai que
cette expulsion va agir comme une espèce
de de de clôture électrique pour les
autres qui va qui vont se visualiser
très vite le les limites qui peuvent pas
dépasser, les choses qui peuvent pas
dire, les les limites qui peuvent pas
franchir. Donc ça a beaucoup joué dans
le dans l'autocensure de tous les de
tous mes mes 200 confrères là qui qui
sont là. Et alors après, il y a pas que
ça. Après, il y a des trucs plus il y a
des trucs plus profonds. Il y a le fait
que c'est quoi un correspondant dans un
pays étranger ? C'est essentiellement un
journaliste qui essaie de d'avoir des
sources gouvernementales. Et en fait, à
l'époque comme aujourd'hui, un
correspondant à l'étranger, c'est
quelqu'un qui couvre essentiellement le
gouvernement du pays dans lequel il est.
Quand il a un peu de chance ou un peu de
liberté, il arrive à sortir de la
capitale et aller sur le terrain
rencontrer des gens. Mais sinon c'est
avant tout un journaliste politique et
euh un journaliste politique, c'est un
journaliste qui couvre un parti ou un
gouvernement et il est calibré, il est
formaté pour euh trouver le
l'institution politique qu'il couvre
rationnelle,
raisonnable. Son boulot, c'est
d'expliquer à ses lecteurs pourquoi le
gouvernement a pris telle mesure,
pourquoi le président a a fait tel
discours. Euh et quand il se trouve en
face d'un d'un régime qui est
manifestement et c'est c'est c'est très
vite évident un régime de dingue, ils
savent pas le dire. Ils ont pas les mots
pour dire ça,
tu comprends ?
Oui. Non, non, mais voilà. Euh et alors
non seulement ils savent pas le dire,
mais ils sont euh les règles du jeu pour
eux consistent à continuer à entretenir
des relations normales avec euh les
ministres de l'époque, ce qui est le cas
pour tous les pour tous les
journalistes. Sauf que là les ministres
eux avec qui ils doivent bosser
s'appelle Gebels, Gering
et qu'il faut arriver à à établir des
relations professionelles normales avec
ces ces ces ces gens qui sont qui jouent
pas le jeu. et et donc et donc tout ce
qui va déborder toutes les toutes les
tous les tous les premiers signes et en
fait ils sont très rapides les signes de
barbarie de ce des naz la
conférence de presse de l'ouverture du
camp d'Achud c'est beau ça non
mais c'est formidable on se dit le camp
de Daud les les nazis le le planquaient
et cetera ça a été un secret ça pas du
tout été un secret euh ça a été ouvert
par Guring euh par une conférence de
presse où la la la presse étrangère a pu
poser ces questions. Alors très vite, le
à partir de de de février mars 33, les
les opposants sont enfermés à Daudot par
milliers. Je veux dire, en février 33,
il y a 5000 communistes qui sont
balancés
comme ça dans les camps. Donc ça
arrangé les journalistes de l'époque,
non ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils étaient un peu contre les
communistes, non ?
Oui. Enfin, les les journalistes de
base, pas tellement. Ceux qui sont
contre les communistes, c'est surtout
leurs patrons. Et ça aussi, c'est un
truc très important pour comprendre
pourquoi le traitement d'Hler
a été ce qu'il a été. C'est-à-dire
pourquoi globalement ils ont rien dit.
C'est parce que aux yeux des patrons,
soit les patrons français, britanniques,
américains, la trouille numéro 1, c'est
le communisme. On est on est au début
des années 30, le communisme vient de
s'installer en Urs et la trouille numéro
1 des des milliardaires de l'époque,
c'est l'expansion du communisme. Et pour
eux, Hitler va arrêter le communisme.
Donc, il y a une espèce de de préjugés
favorable quand Hitler quand Hitler
arrive ou en tout cas d'absence de
préjugés défavorable. Bon, on est prêt
on est prêt à à passer sur beaucoup de
choses. Bon et ce qui explique que les
les bon les gars sur place, je t'ai
expliqué, mais les patrons non plus et
les rédactions en chef non plus ne les
poussent pas euh à rencontrer les juifs
à qui sont victimes déjà des premières
persécutions, à rencontrer les
communistes et cetera. Ils sont pas
poussés par leur leur rédaction en chef.
Donc voilà, tout ça fait un ensemble de
raisons pour lesquelles euh en gros de
33 à 39 puisque les les Français et les
Britanniques restent jusqu'en 39, les
Américains jusqu'en 41 jusqu'à
déclaration de guerre après Peur Larbor,
euh ils vont pas raconter grand-chose.
Comment tu as bossé ? Pourquoi ce
bouquin ?
Euh comment j'ai bossé ? J'ai lu les
collections, hein. Je me j'ai bouffé des
j'ai bouffé des articles et des articles
et des articles. Alors, paradoxalement,
c'est plus facile aujourd'hui qu'il y a
20 ans. Ce qui explique peut-être
pourquoi la personne l'a fait avant moi.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, il y a
quand même énormément de choses en
ligne. Tout le New York Times est en
ligne depuis le 19e siècle et avec les
mises en pages d'origine. Ce qui veut
dire que tu peux voir quand tu lis un
article,
un article qui est amorqué en trois
lignes au bout de la page.
Ouais. si tu peux voir s'il est en bas
de la page 7 ou si ou s'il est à la une.
Donc tuas tu as une vision physique du
journal. Bon en France en France toutes
les collections de
le site internet ça s'appelle
Galik. Formidable site fait par la BNF
où tu peux relire au jour le jour le la
presse de l'époque. C'est c'est c'est
c'est passionnant quoi. C'est angoissant
et c'est passionnant.
Bon maintenant qu'on a fini le quart
d'or promo,
d'accord,
on passe aux choses sérieuses.
Bah vas-y.
C pas sérieux là.
Non. Si si c'était sérieux. C'était
d'ailleurs très sérieux mais est-ce
qu'il y a des parallèles à faire avec
notre époque ?
Bah plein. Enfin, tu l'as lu. Ah
je je suis pas arrivé à la fin.
Ah bah c'est con parce que les
parallèles, ils sont à la fin.
Merde. [rires]
Donc on va se les faire ensemble.
Oui. Voilà.
On va spoiler un peu alors
voilà
les parallèles. Il y a quoi ? Il y a les
parallèles, si tu veux. Le le le livre,
comment il est né ? Le livre il est né
après l'élection de Trump. le Trump si
tu te souviens,
cette sidération intergalactique dans
tous les médias
et surtout américain et surtout
américain. Euh c'est c'est marrant parce
que pour arrê sur image donc le le le
site, on a beaucoup suivi le la
médiatisation des des primaires enfin de
la campagne de 2016, celle qui a élu
Trump et on a vu les émissions
[grognement] américaines, les toch show,
les L show où tous les journalistes se
marraaient au début. En parlant de
la candidature de Trump, je veux dire,
tu as les les les plus grandes stars du
journaliste américain qui t'expliquaient
que jamais non seulement il serait élu,
mais même il serait jamais le candidat
républicain. Tu on a vu ces images et
quand Trump pas a été élu, il y a eu une
espèce de sidération intergalatique
comme tu dis de de beaucoup de confrères
qui sont dit "Mais attends, on qu'est-ce
qu'on a raté ? Comment on a pu rater ça
?" Et c'est à ce moment-là que plusieurs
d'entre eux euh sont allés rechercher
dans les collections de la montée
d'Hitler pour essayer de voir si les les
devanciers euh avaient été meilleurs
queux ou pas. Et c'est ça qui m'a donné
l'idée en fait.
C'est quoi lesvanciers ?
Bah lesvanciers c'est c'est les
journalistes des années 20 et 30, ceux
qui ceux qui avaient fait le boulot
avant, les prédécesseurs si tu préfères,
je sais pas comment on peut dire.
Et voilà, l'idée, elle vient de là. Et
ce qui m'a vraiment donné envie de ce
qui m'a vraiment fait me dire "J'ai un
sujet si tu veux, c'est l'histoire du
Saint-Louis."
Le bateau qui fait des tours et des
tours avec les juifs à l'intérieur, qui
cherche
un bateau qui part de Hambourg avec 1000
réfugiés juifs à l'intérieur, des
Allemands, des Autrichiens.
Euh les les les réfugiés sont sûrs que
ils vont pouvoir demander l'asile aux
États-Unis en passant par Cuba. Enfin,
ils ont ils ont ils ont monté leur truc
et en fait
à Cuba, on les laisse pas débarquer et
aux États-Unis non plus. Et pendant 10
jours, le bateau va faire des ronds dans
l'eau au large de New York, puis ensuite
au large de la Floride, il descend un
peu euh avec des gens qui négocient, qui
essayent de de fléchir le gouvernement
américain pour qu'on laisse débarquer.
Finalement, le gouvernement américain,
il laisse pas débarquer. Je veux dire,
c'est des gens qui ont fuit. On est en
39, c'est très important. On est en mai
juin 39 et c'est des gens qui ont fuit
euh l'Europe. Je veux dire en 39, alors
en 33 peut-être qu'on savait pas bien
mais en 39 Hitler on connaît, on sait ce
que c'est et on sait le sort qui attend
les juifs euh qui vont rester qui vont
rester en Allemagne. On est après le
notamment la nuit de cristal là dont on
a célébré le 80e anniversaire le weekend
dernier.
Et alors moi j'ai plongé dans les
collections du New York Times. Je me
suis dit mais ils vont faire la une tous
les jours. Tous les jours ils vont
essayer de faire monter des reporters
sur le bateau, interroger les familles
parce que les réfugiés qui sont sur le
bateau ont des familles aux États-Unis
et tout. Je veux dire, ils vont faire du
enfin ils savent faire le New York
Times, c'est ça ? Et pendant 10 15
jours, que dalle.
que dal, c'est-à-dire des des des brèves
ultra froid en page intérieure, ultra
factuel.
Par exemple, aucune interpellation
à Roosevelt, au président Roosevelt pour
lui dire "Faites une exception, ouvrez
le port, recevez-les, ils sont là."
Rien. Ce que tu aurais pu imaginer être.
Tu sais quand on dit les médias
américains, les médias américains, tu
les imagines tous, courant dans tous les
sens, interpellant le pouvoir, le
premier amendement, la liberté de la
presse et cetera, rien.
[raclement de gorge]
Et je me suis dit comment il se fait
qu'en 39 euh le New York Times peut
avoir un traitement aussi inhumain.
Et en fait voilà, c'est ce qui j'ai
envie de comprendre et le bouquin c'est
pour ça.
Trump maintenant, ils l'ont pas vu
arriver. la sidération.
Qu'est-ce que [raclement de gorge]
qu'est-ce que ça ça reflète de notre
société journalistique du 21e siècle ?
Bah son enfermement. Alors, s'agissant
des médias américains, ça reflète son
enfermement de dans la bulle new
yorco-wingtonienne. Je veux dire, Trump
a été élu non pas à New York et
Washington, mais par le un certain
nombre d'États, dont les États de la
Rust Belt, les les États industriels euh
où tous les journalistes américains se
sont dit "Mon dieu, on n'y est pas assez
allé". Tu vois, de de la même manière.
Non, mais ça ça je veux dire, c'est la
même chose en France. euh à ch enfin
dans les 30 dernières années euh à
chaque fois que Le Pen père ou fille ont
fait un bon résultat si tu veux à la au
présidentiel au législative ou à ce que
tu veux tu as une espèce de de de cri
d'effroi de de des journalistes français
français qui se disent "Mon dieu, on n
pas allé sur le terrain, on n pas assez
vu les gens, on n pas assez parlé aux
gens". Je veux dire l'enfermement
journalistique, il est français, il est
américain,
il est sans doute fait comment pour
combattre ça ? On sort,
on sort, on sort des des des
confortables arrondissements parisiens
où nous sommes en ce moment et [rires]
on va voir les gens si tu veux. Moi moi
je te disais, je mon job à partir de 92,
ça a été de critiquer les médias. Mais
avant, j'ai j'ai fait une une douzaine
d'années comme reporter au monde.
J'étais j'étais sans arrêt barré à
droite à gauche, à la campagne, couvrant
un procès, couvrant un fait d'hiver,
salaire de misère. Euh non pour un
salaire confortable au monde salaire
combien
à l'époque mais je sais plus c'était en
France je crois que c'était genre je
crois qu'on était payé genre 10000 mais
10000 ce qu' ferait aujourd'hui 1500 €
mais 10000 quand je suis entré si tu
veux c'était formidable hein c'était
c'est non je j'ai j'ai toujours été très
bien payé au monde il y a pas de
problème. Combien tu prends là
où
ar sur image,
il faut c'est le
Non mais moi je veux bien dire, il y a
il y a aucun souci. Mais alors à ce
moment-là, est-ce qu'on pourra parler du
modèle économique de de Syerview ?
On va y venir. On va il y a pas de modè
il y a pas de modèle économique. Bah
c'estd
on est tous bénévoles, on prend un peu
de tune sur Tipi, ça nous p les
éclairages, le loyer, tout le Bordwell.
On fait ça, c'était soit ça, soit les
cours de bridge.
Mais alors tout le matos là,
c'est payé par la communauté.
C'est payé par la communauté. Ah ouais,
c'est pas mal.
C'est pas mal. Et vous êtes combien être
bénévole ? Je sais pas, ça varie.
C'està-dire Non, mais vas-y.
Entre 4 et 8.
Et ça fait tourner une émission
hebdomadaire.
Non, c'est aléatoire et erratique.
D'accord. Alors, nous si tu veux arrê
sur image, on a
Attends, attends, réponds à la question.
Ou oui, mais je vais te dire, je vais te
dire, on a un modèle plus professionnel,
c'est-à-dire que c'est une équipe de
neuf personnes, des journalistes,
documentalistes, webmaster et cetera qui
sont payés, qui ont des salaires, qui
ont des CDI. Donc moi je suis comme tout
le monde, j'ai un CDI et un salaire qui
est je te réponds de 4700 € mensuel net.
Ça va ?
B c'est pas c'est pas plus ni pas le le
Tu t'attendais à plus.
Je je te déçois. Je suis [rires] je suis
désolé. Le le principe que j'ai fixé au
début c'est que l'échelle des salaires
de la boîte est de 1 à 3.
Propre. Propre.
Écoute, je te laisse le dire, moi je
suis factuel.
Je te donne l'effet. Je suis heureux
d'avoir ton approbation.
C'est propre. Et euh revenons à nos
moutons. Euh euh comment on fait pour
secouer le le journalisme ? Ça sent
quand même un peu le sapin là
maintenant. Géopolitiquement parlant,
c'est tendu. Il y a des il y a des
réfugiés, il y a des gens réfugiés,
bah des réfugiés climatiques, des
réfugiés économiques, il y a des
déplacements de population, il y a les
États-Unis qui sortent des accords
nucléaires,
ça chauffe. Il y a de la précarité qui
monte en fonction exponentielle. Il y a
des montées des tensions entre les
différentes communautés. Il y a monté
d'extrême gauche, monté d'extrême
droite, montée d'extrême centre. Ça
chauffe. Et les journalistes, on les
sent, on les perçoit de temps en temps
un peu trop sidéré.
Comment on fait pour les pour les aider
?
Comment on fait pour les aider ? Ça
c'est la question
c'est la question. Il y a il y a un truc
que tu as pas cité parce que je pense
que c'est quand même ce qui est beaucoup
plus déstabilisateur pour les
journalistes que si tu veux tout ce que
tu as cité, tout ce que tu as cité, les
réfugiés et cetera, le monde qui va mal,
les journalistes, ils savent gérer ça,
ils savent gérer le monde qui enfin en
tout cas leur job c'est de gérer le
monde qui va mal si tu veux. Et il
préfèrent même gérer le monde qui va mal
que le monde qui va bien.
Ça fait vendre le monde qui
le monde qui le monde qui va bien, ça
les emmerde. Ça les emmerde et ça
emmerde aussi les lecteurs. Je suis
désolé de le dire, je sais pas
politiquement.
Tu te rappelles de ma question ? Oui,
oui, mais je si tu veux je [rires]
j'essaie de de compléter ta question qui
était excellente mais j'essaie de
sans être trop professoral hein.
Mais j'ai j'essaie néanmoins de la sans
t'ennuyer. J'essaie de pas t'ennuyer euh
comme dans le livre d'ailleurs. J'essaie
de pas ennuyer trop le lecteur. Bon non
mais je si tu veux je pense que ce qui
déstabilise les journalistes c'est pas
tellement le monde qui va mal. C'est la
concurrence aujourd'hui des de Twitter
et de Facebook. Je veux dire, c'est ça
mais ben oui, c'est ça qui les
déstabilise beaucoup plus que le monde
qui va mal, c'est la concurrence de
Syerview. C'est c'est
concurrence. Non mais on fait on fait
une concurrence nous.
Mais bien sûr. Non, attends, bien sûr
que tu sais pourquoi tu fais une
concurrence aux journalistes. Je veux
dire pourquoi tu fais tu fais une
concurrence au journalistes tu ça va te
flatter. Non,
si depuis la sortie du livre qui est
sortie début octobre, le c'est la
l'émission qu'on fait aujourd'hui là et
la première émission de télévision qui
m'invite pour parler du livre.
Ben parce que non mais c'est pareil,
c'est juste la première. Donc si tu veux
62 vues sur une radio et un petit
passage sur une télé suisse, une radio
suisse.
Oui. Non mais il y a des j'ai été invité
par des radios, il y a des articles et
cetera mais la télévision
[raclement de gorge] française
aujourd'hui ne s'intéresse pas au sujet
dont on est en train de parler. Donc
c'est dans ce sens-là que je te dis que
oui, tu concurrences les médias, des
gens comme toi, des nouveaux médias euh
comme Sinw, comme le média, euh comme
euh tous les tout voilà tous les tous
les médias bruts, euh l'oopsider et
cetera, j'en oublie plein tous ces
médias de concurrence le donc c'est pour
ça qu'ils vont mal les journalistes
traditionnels dans les médias
traditionnels si tu veux. C'est pas
parce qu'il y a des réfugiés
climatiques, c'est parce que il y a
cette espèce de de de grand océan, si tu
veux, euh cette espèce de lâ de fond euh
qui charit euh le meilleur et le pire,
comme on dit euh et et sur laquelle
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de gens
s'informment. Enfin, je veux dire, je te
je te révèle pas l'histoire de la
campagne de Trump, les fake news, les
intox, euh tout ce que tu veux. Et et
pour eux, si tu veux, c'est terrible.
Pour eux, c'est terrible parce que alors
parce que eux, ils sont habitué à depuis
depuis des décennies à une certaine
pratique professionnelle si tu veux avec
ses bons et ses mauvais côtés. Les bons
côtés, c'est que quand même ils essayent
de vérifier les infos et ils essayent de
voilà de voilà. Et les mauvais côtés, si
tu veux, c'est que les médias sont
aujourd'hui comme en 33 tenus par des
milliardaires, que soit en France, en
Grande-Bretagne ou aux États-Unis et
donc ils sont dans un dans un dans un
suivisme et dans un dans un biais
idéologique qui ne savent pas. Donc je
veux dire le les les médias
traditionnels aujourd'hui, voilà, c'est
ça. Bon et tout d'un coup leur arrive
sur la gueule le Twitter, Facebook
machin qui poste sa vidéo. Euh
Jacqueline je sais plus quoi, la euh la
la gilet jaune de Bretagne là, je je son
nom m'échable si tu veux qui fait je ne
sais combien de centaines de milliers de
vues sur
Jacqueline. Jacqueline c'est pas un
média.
Mais bien sûr que si. Jacqueline c'est
un média. Jacqueline c'est un média.
J'atline sur le sur le blocage euh sur
le blocage des gilets jaunes, si tu
veux, elle a un impact beaucoup plus
important que tout ce que peut dire la
ministre des transports ou la ministre
de l'écologie. Et d'ailleurs, tu as vu
euh donc Jacques Jacquelin a fait son sa
vidéo 5 jours après, tu as la la
ministre de l'écologie qui lui a répondu
de de la même manière en en essayant de
se se faire filmer dans sa cuisine avec
un plan super serré pour qu'on voit pas
l'appartement autour. Donc donc voilà
donc le le l'univers médiatique
aujourd'hui c'est ça et ce qui
déstabilise aujourd'hui les journalistes
c'est ça. Bon et si tu veux tu me
demandes comment sauver la presse. Je
veux dire je suis très honoré que tu me
demandes comment sauver la presse si tu
veux. Je pense juste que sauver la la
presse va devoir se sauver elle-même et
elle va devoir se sauver elle-même
d'abord en affrontant cette concurrence
là. Mais elle commence à le faire. Je
veux dire il y a il y a des voilà il y a
des il y a des gens classiques qui
commencent à plonger dans ce dans ce
dans ces médias là. et ensuite en en
faisant son objet si tu veux. Je veux
dire parce que c'est bien joli la vidéo
virale, c'est bien joli les trucs et les
machins si tu veux mais à un moment
quand même le alors alors
[raclement de gorge] il y a deux façons
de voir si tu veux. Il y a il y a deux
façons de voir les 10 ans qui viennent
pour la presse. Il y a la manière
optimiste et la manière pessimiste pour
les journalistes. La manière optimiste,
c'est de se dire il y aura toujours une
place pour le journalisme professionnel.
Il y aura toujours une place pour les
journalistes qui vont vérifier les
trucs, qui vont aller sur le terrain,
qui vont aller au péril de leur vie en
Syrie ou ailleurs pour rapporter des
papiers et cetera. il y aura toujours
une place, il y aura toujours une
demande pour ça. C'est la la demande
subsistera.
C'est en général ce que les journalistes
se disent plutôt pour essayer de se
rassurer. Et la la vision pessimiste
pour le la presse telle qu'elle existe,
c'est de se dire "Bah non,
je veux dire le le la presse selon son
selon le modèle démocratique
traditionnel tel qu'on l'a connu en
Occident, ça a été une parenthèse qui a
duré un siècle, un siècle et demi
disons. démocratie
un peu peut-être comme la démocratie et
on va passer à autre chose. Alors ça je
te cache pas que comme journaliste, moi
c'est un truc qui me terrifie parce que
comme journaliste, je suis formaté comme
tout le monde à une pratique
traditionnelle du journalisme. Si tu
veux je
quand même un peu plus ouvert que la
moyenne. Tu as débarqué sur internet.
Écoute [__] c'est c'est cool de venir
ici. On se fait on se fait faire des je
crois je croyais que ça devait ça devait
être saqué ici.
Non mais t'inquiète pas, tu veux
commencer à boîter dans Non mais si tu
veux, tu vois, je suis moi je suis
formaté. J'ai j'ai fait 25 ans au monde,
ensuite à la télévision publique. J'ai
des réflexes de journalistes
traditionnels. Donc un peu comme tu as
fait avec Jean-Marie Messier là.
Ah euh je savais bien que ça allait
arriver. Bah ils m'ont tweeté cet
après-midi, j'ai regardé, ça m'a fait
rigoler
quoi. Alors vas-y. Jean-Marie Messier,
c'est c'est quoi ce messie
? Tu voulais pas parler des chiffres
parce que on va [rires] tu allis parler
tu allais parler de trucs beaucoup plus
légers et ainsi de suite. Oui.
Ça c'est une pratique journalistique en
général. Non mais ça ça ça n'a rien à
voir ça. Ça je veux dire Jean-Marie
Messier ce truc que j'ai crainé après
pendant 10 ans. Je suis heureux de non
mais ou 15 si tu veux jusqu'à ce que je
sois viré cet après-midi pour la
première fois que je sois viré jusqu'à
ce que je sois viré de France Télé si tu
veux. Quand j'ai été viré de France télé
bon les tous les toutes les attaques sur
le thème il est vendu à Messi est vendu
au grand capital se sont calmés comme
par hasard si tu veux. Jean-Marie
Messier on l'a reçu arrêt sur image qui
est Jean-Marie Messier. Jean-Marie
Messier était le le PDG de Vivindi et le
PDG de Canal Plus. Donc c'était le
c'était à l'époque où où il était au
sommet de sa gloire, on l'appelait
Jisem, c'est-à-dire Jean-Marie Messier,
moi-même maître du monde si tu veux. Et
c'est le c'est le premier si tu veux qui
a eu l'idée ou qui a essayé mais enfin
on s'en fout de tout ça c'est de la
vieille histoire. Non tu veux vraiment
je te raconte ça le temps hein.
Non mais ouais mais c'est juste chiant
mais je veux bien enfin je veux dire il
y a aucun souci.
Euh c'est le premier qui a essayé euh
étant propriétaire des des tuyaux de la
générale des eaux si tu veux rebaptiser
Vivindi de se dire tiens dans ces tuyaux
je pourrais essayer de faire passer des
programmes de télé. Donc il avait
Vivindi, il a racheté Canal Plus pour
mettre des programmes dans ses tuyaux.
Bref, maître du monde
et on le reçoit arrêt sur image mais
arrêt sur image si tu veux on avait pas
c'est notre rôle n'était pas de de
l'interroger sur ces projets industriels
ou de d'essayer de savoir si les comptes
étaient trafiqués. D'ailleurs, à
l'époque personne ne disait que les
comptes de sa boîte étaient trafiqués.
notre rôle puisque c'est en même temps
qu'il était tout ça si tu veux ce mec
passait en permanence dans Paris match
se faisait photographier dans sa cuisine
avec son sandwich et tout il était dans
une bataille d'images si tu veux nous on
s'était on s'était dit bon ben on va
essayer de démonter ses ces images de
mec simple qui a un trou à sa chaussette
effectivement
match avait [rires]
match avait
ça sent la pression monter là
ouais t'inquiète pas non non non mais tu
es très très fort avait publié une
photo de lui avec un trou à sa
chaussette. Donc nous on se dit voilà.
Et effectivement
euh avant que les caméras tournent euh
ton pote comment il s'appelait ?
Attends mais attends mais tu mets tu
mélanges tout, les gens vont rien
comprendre. Non mais elle est super ton
émission mais si tu veux il y a des
rappels pédagogiques qu'il faut faire
parce que c'est bien de faire de la de
la bonne télé avec des coups si tu veux
mais c'est bien aussi d'expliquer les
choses.
Allez vas-y professeur Schneiderman, on
t'écoute. Ben
écoute tes tes tes abonnés jugeront mais
c'est vrai alors ça ça fait partie de
mon format. J'aime bien expliquer les
choses et j'aime bien que les gens
comprennent à peu près et enfin
j'essaye. Et bref le mec s'assoit sur le
plateau et de la même manière que tous
les deux avant que ça tourne on s'est
dit trois gentillesses si tu veux. Je
lui dis trois gentillesses. Je lui dis
vous inquiétez pas, on va pas parler de
chiffres. C'est vrai, le boulot n'était
pas parlé de chiffrees. Bon et donc le
cet extrait là d'avant plateau, il sort
sur je sais plus où sur internet s'il y
avait déjà internet à l'époque. Et alors
là, c'est devenu ouais, le mec a rassuré
Messier avant lui disant qu'on lui
poserait pas de questions saqué et tout.
Voilà. Enfin, ce qui était profondément
débile. Mais tout ça, tu m'as tu m'as
chopé sur Messiers ce que j'étais en
train de te dire que j'étais formaté.
C'est là mais oui oui je suis voilà j'ai
alors après si tu veux après pardon
après le c'est vrai que deux coups de
pied occus successifs du monde et de
France télé m'ont sans doute aidé à me
déformater un peu si tu veux voilà c'est
c'est mais tu sais tu
parles aussi de l'endroit où tu es
tu parles aussi Non mais Bourdieu mon
ami Bourdieu disait mais d'où parlez
d'où parlez-vous
et c'est vrai c'est important euh là on
est dans une cave avec le modèle
économique que tu nous as expliqué. Euh
bon ben je pense que tu tu parles et tu
as le temps de l'endroit où tu es. Euh
on est indépendant, on est tranquille.
Oui. Ben voilà. Bah tu as le ton du mec
indépendant et tranquille. Donc tout va
bien.
Le tu parles de de
d'un philosophe.
Euh est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un d'un
journaliste Pierre Carl ? H
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ? Les
nouveaux chiens de garde, ça te parle ?
Qu'est-ce que ça a de
? Pierre Carl, il faut relier à ce qui
suit si tu veux. C'est c'est lui qui a
sorti cette ces ces 3 minutes de
conversation de small talk avec Messier
en en tirant le la conclusion que
j'étais vendu à Messier si tu veux.
Voilà. Non, mais il faut relier les tu
vois toujours ma mon côté prof, faut
faut relier les choses. Et c'est vrai
que voilà, c'est c'est quelqu'un avec
qui euh alors Pierre Carles, si tu veux,
s'il faut en parler, euh on a un vécu
commun puisque quand j'étais au monde,
si tu veux, il avait souhaité travailler
avec moi, un documentaire sur la classe
politique française qu'on devait traiter
comme un comme un comme un les animaux
d'un zoau si tu veux. C'est ça le but.
Donc, on est allé tourner une fois
ensemble. Alors lui lui il filmait et
moi j'étais censé faire le commentaire
et on allait tourner une fois ensemble à
garder une partie de l'Élysée. C'était
sympa, c'était tout c'est bien, [rires]
c'était mitérant, ça nous rajunit pas,
tu as bien mangé ?
On a rien bouffé parce qu'on
c'était sympa, tout se passait bien. Et
puis à un moment, je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait, il voulait faire un
autre film qu'en fait le film qu'il
voulait faire c'était sur PPDA. il avait
une fixette sur PPDA qui à l'époque
présentait le 20h de TF1 et donc juste à
ce moment-là, j'ai dit bah moi ça
m'amuse pas tellement, ça m'intéresse
pas tellement et donc on a donc j'ai
voilà, on n pas bossé ensemble depuis
euh c'est vrai que je sais pas s'il m'en
voulait ou quoi. Bref, donc qu'est-ce
que je pense de Pierre Carl ? Je pense
que c'est un je pense que le c'est un
bon documentariste enfin qui a fait des
des films qui sont intéressants euh qui
a fait des films qui sont d'une profonde
mauvaise foi si tu veux puisque ce qu'il
a fait avec moi était d'une profonde
mauvaise foi. Donc la mauvaise foi,
c'est un genre c'est un genre efficace.
C'est fastoche d'être de mauvaise foi,
hein. C'est fastoche de C'est fastoche
de l'effet de télé, le le montage télé.
Euh moi, j'ai accepté de venir ici chez
toi d'abord parce que je suis interviewé
nulle part, donc c'est c'est trouvé ça
sympa. Et ensuite parce que c'est en
direct sans montage si tu veux. Et donc
je sais que si tu veux tu vas peut-être
me choper sur des trucs. Moi je vais te
choper sur des trucs mais de toute façon
ce sera sans montage. Donc [grognement]
ça
à la loyale
à la loyale. Donc donc ça me va. Bon
Pierre Carl à l'inverse c'est un c'est
un c'est un gars qui pratique le film
ultra monté si tu veux monter monter de
mauvaise fois en faisant dire aux gens
le contraire de ce qu'ils ont dit en en
choisissant les 6 secondes qui vont bien
si tu veux. Voilà donc voilà c'est un
genre. Après, j'ai beaucoup aimé les
derniers films qu'il a fait sur
l'Équateur, sur Coréa en Équateur et sur
le sur la manière dont dont les les les
médias français ont totalement ignoré
l'exprè le l'expérience de gauche
équatorienne parce qu'ils en ont rien à
branler et qui voilà ça j'ai trouvé ça
très bien.
Tu veux tu veux nous choper sur quoi ?
Ah mais sur rien.
D'accord. Non mais non mais par exemple
sur les questions, j'ai commencé à te
choper sur tes questions, tu vois la
question. Bon alors racontez-nous votre
livre si tu veux. Moi reste sur image,
c'est exactement la question de j'ai
vide si tu veux.
Ah bon ?
Oui. [rires]
C'est tu est-ce que tu comprends
pourquoi ?
Ouais c'est c'est trop binéaire quoi.
Bah oui puis c'est euh [rires] Mais non
mais si tu veux
tu un petit jus d'orange ?
Non non pourquoi ? Non c'est il est
insuculant. On a un jus d'orange
extraordinaire ici. On est formidable là
pour l'instant. On a proposé que de
l'eau. Mais c'est [rires]
bon, restons un peu sérieux. Euh le
formatage des journalismes,
comment on fait ? Comment on fait pour
récupérer la confiance de son public ?
Déjà, on parle à la première personne.
On dit "Je
on dit je". Je je veux dire le
journalisme. Le journaliste. Alors, je
te disais tout à l'heure,
il est d'où il parle et puis il est il
est aussi qui il est.
On est dans une cave, tu peux parler
dans ta cave.
On l'a dit. Euh, le journaliste, il est
qui est ? C'est un homme, c'est une
femme ou entre les deux ? Ou entre les
deux. Euh, [rires] je je Ou entre les
deux. Euh je te je te l'attends. Euh
attends pas trop, hein.
D'accord. C'est fait comme ça. Euh il
est jeune, il est vieux, il est blanc,
il est noir, il est propriétaire de son
logement ou il est locataire, il habite
une ville moyenne où il habite une
grande ville, je veux dire. Et ça joue.
Il est
il est il a une pratique religieuse où
il en a pas. Ça joue sur sa manière de
voir le monde si tu veux. Pendant très
longtemps, les journalistes se sont dit
euh et beaucoup se le disent encore, on
parle de nulle part.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? On est le
on est l'objectivité incarnée. On est
forcément objectif puisqu'on est
journaliste. Ou alors oui, si on bosse
au Figaro, on accepte implicitement
qu'on est de droite. Si on bosse je sais
pas où, on accepte au médias, on accepte
implicitement qu'on est de gauche. Et on
met ça dans le pack de lecture. Mais si
tu veux, le moi ce que j'ai appris au
CFJ, ce que j'ai fait le le CFJ, le
centre de formation des journalistes,
c'est le journaliste se met pas en
avant. Je veux dire, il doit être
extérieur à l'information qui bon et je
pense que ça marche plus.
Ça ça m'a ça t'étonne ? On t'étonne pas
ça.
Ça t'étonne ? Si, je m'étonne que tu
t'étonnes. On t'écoute, on voit faire
des grands gestes. Non non mais
si tu veux, je pense que ça marche plus
parce que sur internet on dit jeu.
Sur internet on dit je. Je veux dire le
on dit on
Non, sur internet on dit je. Le les les
tweetos disent je. Euh il y a 10 ans,
les blogueurs disaient "Je les" Il y a
10 ans, les blogueurs, ils ont ils ont
fait entrer le jeu dans le discours
journalistique si tu veux et que les
gens euh le le public est voilà, le
public il sait bien tout ce que je viens
de te dire là, que le journaliste il est
bourgeois ou pas bourgeois, en général
bourgeois euh il est blanc, il est noir
et cetera et ça joue sur ta façon de de
sur ça joue sur ton appréhension de
l'actualité. Donc je pense qu'une des
manières une des manières de de de
survivre dans le nouvel écosystème si tu
veux c'est c'est d'assumer sa
subjectivité, c'est d'assumer son jeu.
Journalisme d'opinion,
son jeu. Son jeu. Alors son jeu. Je vais
te donner un je vais te donner un
exemple personnel.
J'ai
euh il se trouve que euh
dans ma vie à un moment euh on s'est
séparé avec la mère de mes enfants
et ça a été pour moi une grande
souffrance et un moment très difficile.
Je veux dire, dans les années qui ont
suivi, je me suis absten traiter des
questions qui touchaient au divorce, aux
familles monoparentales,
aux pères qui élèvent leurs enfants
parce que je savais que ça ce serait des
questions sur lesquelles euh
tu aimes pas te faire mal en fait.
Alors, c'est marrant ce que je pense que
je suis un peu mao quand même, mais là
bah je veux dire, tu te fais pas virer
deux fois si tu es pas quand même
quelque part un peu mao
ou que tu aimes ton boulot
ou que tu aimes trop ton boulot ou les
deux. Mais euh mais c'est vrai que des
fois je le cherche, enfin il a pu
m'arriver, je le cherchais un peu puis
ça peut m'arriver encore. Mais bref, si
tu veux voilà, tu tu es qui tu es avec
le vécu tu as. Je connais pas le tien si
tu veux. Euh mais je pense qu'il faut
apprendre au je pense qu'on devrait
apprendre dans les écoles si tu veux aux
journalistes euh à mieux se connaître
eux-même.
Donc j'ouvre une parenthèse question
internet. Quelles seraient ces
préconisations quant à la formation au
journalisme ?
Bah j'y étais justement. [__] les
grands esprits se rencontrent hein.
Euh je pense ils sont beaucoup là.
Je pense que il faut je pense qu'il
faudrait mieux leur apprendre
l'introspection. L'introspection. Se
connaître. Connaître ses biais tu vois.
connaître ses biens, euh les les
accepter et ensuite bosser avec en faire
du en faire du matériau. Le deuxème truc
Le deuxième truc, il y en aurait
plusieurs hein. Euh le deuxème truc
c'est que euh je crois qu'un journaliste
doit doit doit savoir dire je sais pas.
Le journaliste par définition la la fixe
une des fictions journalistiques si tu
veux, c'est que le journaliste comme il
est il délivre de l'information au
public, il est censé savoir, il est il
est présumé omniscient. C'est débile.
C'est débile.
Moi, il y a plein de trucs que je sais
pas. Si tu veux, j'anime une émission
chaque semaine, chaque semaine sur un
sujet très différent, si tu veux. Euh je
suis pas omniscient sur les sujets. Il y
en a que je maîtrise mieux que d'autres.
Si dès que ça parle un peu d'histoire ou
de la ou de la seconde guerre mondiale,
j'arrive à peu près ou de l'histoire
politique, j'arrive à peu près. Mais par
exemple, quand on fait des émissions
scientifiques sur un rê sur image, si tu
veux, je suis une bille en science. Donc
je veux pas jouer à l'omniscient et et
presque si tu veux euh c'est un atout
parce que ça m'amène à poser au aux gens
qui viennent des questions naïves.
Euh moi un des trucs qu'on m'a m'a
toujours appris enfin que ce soit mes
d'ailleurs mes parents ou euh c'est à ne
jamais avoir peur de poser une question
idiote. Je pense qu' un journaliste ça
doit jamais avoir peur de poser une
question idiote. Ça doit jamais se dire
oh là non je vais passer pour un con. Si
je la pose, c non, tu passes jamais pour
un con en fait. Ou si tu passes pour un
con, tu en as rien à [__] parce que
ceux qui te regardent, c'est ils sont
cons aussi et ils sont comme toi, ils
savent pas. Donc si tu veux, tu tu poses
la question qui tu poses la question qui
se pose. Et euh le dernier truc, c'est
qu'il faut pas avoir peur de dire "Je me
suis planté."
Tu t'es déjà planté ?
Mais ouais, je me Mais oui, tu te
plantes si tu veux. Je fais je fais tous
les matins euh une chronique sur le site
d'arrêt sur image s'appelle le 915 elle
est tous les matins en ligne à 9h15
précise. C'est un peu mon échauffement
matinal si tu veux. C'est un truc c'est
une contrainte que je me suis fixé parce
que je pense que c'est bien dans un
média d'avoir des rendez-vous. Donc
c'est c'est le rendez-vous. Et donc le
pacte de lecture c'est que elle est
faite à l'arrache. Je l'écris le matin
juste avant de la mettre en juste avant
de la mettre en ligne. Et le pack de
lecture avec les abonnés d'arrê sur
image et gens qui la lisent si tu veux
c'est qu'elle est faite à l'arrache.
Donc elle est pas forcément toujours
très complète euh que effectivement je
dis là ouais la presse n'a pas parlé de
tout ça et tout. Bah il y a peut-être un
truc un un papier dans un coin qui a pu
m'échapper et en général dans l'heure si
tu veux le journaliste se manifeste et
dit mais je l'ai écris moi. Regarde là.
Bon et donc à ce moment-là, je je
rajoute, je complète et cetera. Euh
c'est
encore un peu sur la confiance, non ?
Ouais. Bah sur sur la confiance, c'est
ça. C'est c'est tu t'es planté, tu dis
"Tu t'es planté et ça c'est
tous les journalistes économiques qui
ont jamais vu la la crise économique
débarquer, il faut faire quoi ? Il faut
leur demander de faire amende honorable
ou il faut tous les virer ?
Oui. Euh mais non, mais moi je suis pour
virer personne. Je veux dire, je je j'ai
envie de j'ai j'ai envie de virer
personne. Euh j'ai j'ai
les journalistes économiques. Alors
oui, bah les journalistes économiques,
tu veux. Oui, si c'est s'ils avaient été
plus nombreux effectivement à
reconnaître qu'ils ont pas vu arriver la
la la crise économique, je pense que le
le journalisme économique serait plus
crédible. Oui, mais tu sais les en fait
tous les journalistes ont horreur de ça.
ont horreur de ça. Et
bon, j'ai fait 25 ans au monde, au monde
il y avait une anti
C'est ça ton âge en fait hein.
C'est sympa. [__] mais je suis pas
venu pour rien.
Attends, tu vas voir la deuxième qui
arrive. Je [rires] je suis pas venu pour
rien. Au monde, on avait une antise si
tu veux. Tu sais, c'est un des trucs les
plus sympas qu'on m dit dans les depuis
longtemps. Bref, pas mon âge. Ouais. Et
on voit plus aux soirées d'ailleurs
hein.
Bon, tu as pas compris.
Non, c'est pas grave. Valard, tu vois au
moins on avait une antice, c'était le
les les droits de réponse quand il y
avait quelqu'un qui était pas content de
l'article qu'on avait écrit qui envoyait
un droit de réponse. Et donc vraiment le
jeu c'était comment on va faire pour ne
pas publier son droit de réponse parce
qu'on est oblé les journaux sont obligés
de les publier. Si c'est envoyé dans les
formes au directeur de la publication,
recommander et tout, ils sont obligés de
le publier. Et la antise du monde, c'est
comment faire pour pas publier ? C'est
débile. C'est débile un droit de
réponse. Je veux dire, tu tuas un droit
de réponse, tu le publies. S'il est
justifié, tu écris en dessous "Désolé,
monsieur machin, on s'est trompé." S'il
est pas justifié, tu écris en dessous
"Nous maintenons nos informations et
monsieur machin est une mauvaise fois."
Mais tu voilà ce que Internet a apporté,
c'est ça. Ce que Internet a checking
live,
non, la conversation.
La et le fight checking, mais la
conversation. Si si on parlait de Je te
donne deux questions comme ça ça te
permettra de te préparer un peu.
[soupir][souffle coupé]
On parle de du futur de l'investigation
sur internet et on va parler de de Bon,
on commence là-dessus, ce sera très
bien. Le futur de l'investigation sur
internet. Le futur du journalisme
d'investigation, c'est quoi ?
Ah, je suis nul sur le futur.
[rires]
Je suis nul sur le futur. Je sais pas.
Je C'est quoi la question ? Est-ce que
qui va succéder à Élise Lu ? C'est c'est
quoi la question ?
Les méthodes de travail des journalistes
d'investigation, est-ce que ça va
changer ? Est-ce que
Bah ça a déjà changé à cause de à cause
de la de la NSA, de la surveillance ?
Non non mais attends, c'est excuse-moi
mais c'est pas le futur, c'est le
présent ça. Je veux dire le le ça ça a
déjà énormément changé le le tous les
consortiums de journalistes aujourd'hui
voilà qui se qui se qui se qui se
mettent ensemble si tu veux pour pour
enquêter sur des sujets maous euh comme
l'évasion fiscale ou le la corruption et
cetera. C'est c'est une révolution
considérable dans le journalisme. Et ça
pour le coup euh on parlait tout à
l'heure des voix de par lesquelles ils
peuvent essayer de se se sauver si tu
veux. Euh çaen est une. Çaen est une. Le
le fait d'unir ses forces c'est c'est
tout à fait nouveau si tu veux. C'est
tout à fait nouveau de voir 5 10 15 20
médias de pays différents si tu veux
unir leurs forces pour exploiter un fond
de Wikileaks ou je ou de je ne sais quoi
si tu veux. les les quelques tentatives
qu'il y a eu de de collaboration entre
Wikileaks et la et la [grognement]
presse traditionnelle qui sont pas
toujours très bien passé. Mais en tout
cas euh bah oui, c'est super
intéressant.
Les fake news, c'est de la faute des
journalistes.
Bah les fake news euh
à cause de l'érosion de la confiance,
l'érosion de
Oui. Ben voilà. Non mais c'est tout ça
mais je dirais c'est à la fois le c'est
à la fois la ça nous ramène un peu au
début de la conversation. C'est à la
fois la faute des journalistes et euh
c'est un c'est un territoire pour eux.
C'est un c'est un territoire pour eux
puisque mais ça nous ramène à ce qu'on
disait. Je veux dire, je je pense que
dans un univers de fake news, de trucs
qui se baladent et cetera, on sait
jamais d'où ça vient, d'où vient la
vidéo, qui l'a posté, la moitié des la
moitié des des élèves aujourd'hui dans
certains établissements si tu veux,
crois aux Illuminati, tout ça. Euh je je
je pense qu'à un moment va revenir le
besoin de d'une information certifiée,
j'en peux au RTF.
Alors ça évidemment c'est la caricature
c'est la caricature facile et
effectivement c'est l'autre épouvantail
l'autre épouv alors tuas tu as l'épouv
tu as un épouvantail c'est le les fake
news et tu as l'épouvantail symétrique
si tu veux comme les les ser livres là
le ser livre symétrique c'est l'ORTF
évidemment évidemment que l'ORTF c'est
pas une solution et quoi entre les deux
? Bah entre les deux, il peut y avoir
des nouveaux médias. Euh euh je veux
dire le ce qui a apporté médiia part,
c'est pas mal quand même. C'est pas mal
ce qui a apporté à R sur image non plus.
Oui. Avec moins de moyens et moins
d'impact que Médiia part et on va dire
sur un territoire plus étroit. Mais oui
oui euh non mais oui enfin je veux dire
euh déjà la première chose si tu veux
c'est de alors on parlait de nos modèles
économiques et je te taquinais sur la
gratuité si tu veux mais
fondamentalement
je ne crois pas à la gratuité enfin
c'est très bien ce que vous faites là
c'est très bien
sour onte personne on fait nos petits
trucs dans notre cours
oui c'est c'est c'est formidable mais en
même temps je veux pas être méchant avec
toi si tu veux mais non mais je je veux
pas être méchant mais si tu veux les
question que tu me poses, c'est alors
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ton livre et
qu'est-ce que tu penses de l'avenir ? Je
veux dire, on n'est pas avec les
questions que tu poses et qui sont très
sympas, mais on n'est pas dans un un
journalisme très offensif si tu veux. Tu
tu vois, alors tu as retrouvé Pierre
Carles et tout, c'est super mais on
n'est pas dans un journaliste ultra
documenté et ultra offensif. Merci,
t'inquiète, attends, on arrive. [rires]
Mais oui, ça fait quatre fois que tu me
dis ça. Tu Je suis sûr,
tu m'as dit que tu arrivais pas à tenir
plus de 57 minutes. Donc là, ça fait 57
minutes. Donc on est bon. [rires]
On commencer la cuisine.
Non, mais tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? C'est
c'est
on écoute.
Non, mais un un une
Est-ce que tu penses que les
journalistes qui ont travaillé sur le le
conflit iraquen
Ouais,
c'était des questions vraiment
invasives. Est-ce que c'était des
questions qui étaient pénétrantes ?
Est-ce que les gars quand ils faisaient
leur reportage depuis leur leur
toilettes avec les Scud qui qui
tombaient dans tous les sens, c'était
quoi ? Est-ce que la guerre en Irak, les
journalistes ont poussé les populations
à rentrer en guerre ? Est-ce que ça
c'est aussi de qualité ?
Mais bien sûr que non.
Je veux dire bien sûr que la
c'était dans le domaine de la
conversation, il relayait la propagande
de guerre des ministères des affaires
étrangères. C'était quoi ?
Si si tu essayes de me dire si tu veux,
je te pose une question, j'ai pas besoin
de dire des choses. Les inox de la
guerre d'Irak si tu veux, c'est
formidable. les le les le et que la
manière dont toute la presse américaine
si tu veux a marché a marché a marché au
au
truc chimique au moyen de comment on
disait armes de destruction massive
aux armes, excuse-moi, aux armes de
destruction massive si tu veux mais bien
sûr que c'est un scandale
journalistique, c'est une faillite
journalistique, on est bien d'accord et
c'est pas une solution non plus. On est
d'accord, je veux dire c'est tu vois, tu
regardes sur image euh je veux dire, on
n'est pas des gens qui faisont l'éloge
quotidien ou hebdomadaire de la presse
telle qu'elle est. Euh simplement, je
veux dire entre alors entre l'ORTF d'une
part euh tes tes journalistes américains
sur l'Irak, c'est un peu la même chose
en fait les journalistes les
journalistes américains sur l'Irak
c'était l'ORTF aux États-Unis si tu
veux. Céit c'était ça
un peu les Français aussi non ?
Oui mais tout le monde. Mais bien sûr
entre [grognement] ça et les fake news,
je veux dire je
C'est une fake news
quoi
de les arnes de destruction massives.
Ah ben bien sûr mais c'était une fake
news écrite dans les journaux écrite
dans New York Time. C'est le Washington
Post. Voilà. Alors, entre les fake news,
YouTube,
Facebook, tout ce que tu veux si tu
veux, je je je veux croire qu'il y aura
qui restera la place pour un journaliste
un journalisme professionnel et
indépendant. Mais professionnel,
c'est pas trop tard dans l'opinion
publique professionn Ben, j'en sais
rien. Peut-être que si. Peut-être que
si. Ouais, peut-être que si. Mais je te
l'ai dit tout à l'heure. Peut-être que
c'est fini en fait. Bon, je te dis, je
veux croire, je veux croire.
Ça reste dans le dogme.
Mais mais mais je veux croire mais
peut-être que c'est fini, peut-être que
ça reviendra pas. Peut-être que c'est
trop tard, peut-être que ils ont glissé
si tu veux. Peut-être qu'ils ont ils ont
glissé trop profond. Mais je veux
croire. Mais ce que je voudrais juste
dire si tu veux, c'est que enquêter
c'est un métier et c'est du temps. C'est
beaucoup de temps de et c'est oui, c'est
du pognon de demande au journalistes de
Média Part ou demande au journalistes
des consortiums si tu veux le temps qui
passe sur une enquête. Voilà de
donc le modèle économique du
journalisme, on en fait quoi ? Tu as des
idées ?
Bah le modèle économique du journalisme
si tu veux c'est c'est ce que c'est il y
a pas de il y a pas de secret, je pense.
Tu connais disclos
quoi ? disclose
super enfin super l'idée
alors c'est des c'est des journalistes
qui vont essayer alors là pour le coup
l'indépendance totale c'està-dire de se
faire financer si j'ai bien compris
uniquement par qu'est-ce qui bank ou des
des crowfundings ou alors je je suis pas
sûr soit aussi clair que ça parce que je
pense qu'ils ont pas exclu non plus
d'avoir des messenes euh à partir du
moment où les messes se mêleront pas de
de commander les papiers si tu veux euh
mais oui enfin tout ce qui oui La
tentative disclos génial. Moi je je
souhaite que ça marche. Je souhaite que
ça marche. Ça fait partie de la palette
de choses si tu veux qui peuvent euh
faire revenir la confiance.
Bon question d'internet. Comment vous
informer ?
Comment vous vous informez ?
[__] ils sont ils sont chi ils sont
chiés sur internet aussi.
On commence pas à les provoquer non
plus, hein. [rires]
Comment je m'informe ? Euh beaucoup par
Twitter.
Non mais si tu veux le le
Non mais ce que ce que j'ai ce que ce
que j'ai fini de faire si tu veux c'est
de lire un journal de la première à la
dernière page un journal papier de
regarder un 20h en commençant un 20h et
en finissant à 20h45. Ça c'est fini ça.
Je suis passé de l'autre côté
maintenant. Donc comment je m'informe ?
ma journée d'information si tu veux elle
commence sur Twitter euh parce que je
pense que pour un pour un journaliste,
savoir se se constituer son fil Twitter,
c'est un des c'est un truc fondamental
si tu veux par que c'est c'est ce qui va
te c'est ce qui va constituer ton ton
alimentation. Euh puis Twitter m'emmène
dans des journaux américains, m'emmène
sur des blog sur des sites, m'emmène
dans un papier du monde, m'emmène sur
une vidéo virale.
Tu air, tu revendiques le droit à
l'érance sur Twitter.
Je surf.
Euh, tu vas pas dans les dîners où il y
a des hommes politiques, tu vas pas là
où il y a des des hommes d'affaires pour
prendre de l'information comme ça.
Pauvre, pauvre, pauvre. [rires]
Ni aujourd'hui ni hier.
Pourquoi ? Ça représente un risque ?
Euh non, j'aime pas ça.
Tu as déjà fait ?
Ouais, un peu.
Où ça ? Quand ?
Un peu ? Il y a un moment où je Alors si
tu veux les déjeuners avec les
politiques, j'en ai j'ai j'ai tu sais
les déjeuners où les politiques invite
invite 15 journalistes
trier sur le volet où tu as pas le droit
de raconter ensuite ce qui s'est passé
si tu veux. J'ai dû en faire deux ou
trois et puis je voilà tout le monde.
Il y en a beaucoup des choses comme ça
hein
des des des déjeuners, des dîners ou les
journalistes sans
sans arrêt. Je veux dire les les
journalistes politiques des médias
traditionnels si tu veux ou les
journalistes économiques sont sans arrêt
en train de déjeuner avec des
et de dîner. Non.
Le dîner du siècle ça te parle ?
Ah oui le dîner du siècle ça parle.
C'est quoi c'est quoi le dîner du siècle
? Bah le dîner du siècle, tu tu sais
bien, c'est un c'est un dîner qui est
organisé place de la Concorde à
l'automobile club de France si tu veux
où euh
où euh se mêle des des je crois sont des
centaines de membres de l'establishment
qui soit Intello
euh ministre, ancien ministre, futur
ministre, patron, sous-patron et cetera
et des journalistes.
Mais ça, je suis pas contre ça, je veux
dire. Alors bon, ce ce truc a été
extrêmement attaqué et tout et les
journalistes qui participe ont dit, je
me souviens par exemple de PuJadas qui
qui avait été interrogé là-dessus et
PuJadas a dit "Mais enfin c'est
formidable, je peux je peux dîner à la
même table que un professeur au collège
de France, le patron de PSA,
le futur ministre de de d'Hicot vert."
Bon ça me choque pas que des
journalistes si tu veux aillent chercher
de l'information, ça me choque pas. Le
seul truc qui me choque dans le dîner du
siècle, c'est que tu as pas le droit de
raconter ce que tu as entendu quand tu
es journaliste.
Ce qui est ce qui est c'est c'est comme
tous ces truc Bilderberg, on avait fait
une émission sur Bilderberg dans R sur
Image. Tu veux le seul truc qui est un
peu ennuyeux, c'est que tu as pas le
droit de raconter ce que tu as entendu.
Bon euh à la limite moi, si tu veux, je
vais te dire, je je pourrais raconter
tout ce que j'ai entendu. Ça ça me
dérangerait pas d'aller dans ces
machins.
On va on va te montrer un truc euh et tu
vas nous dire ce que tu en penses.
Est-ce que est-ce que l'équipe est prête
pour te montrer les choses ?
Donc on a on a été cet été un festival
du journalisme.
Ouais.
À couture sur Garon.
Pour l'instant, l'écran est noir là.
Ouais. Ben c'est normal.
Vas-y, balance.
C'est pour lancer un peu le débat sur
cette idée de connivance qui parfois se
joue sur des petits détails mais qui
peut nous piéger nous journalistes. Donc
maintenant, je voudrais puisque j'ai
trois prestigieux invités qui ont frayé
avec la la classe politique depuis des
années ou des décennies, j'aimerais bien
que chacun d'entre vous puisse nous
livrer une anecdote qui illustre cette
conivance entre guillemets ou les fois
où ils se sont sentis piégés ou dans une
situation de connivance parce que ça a
forcément dû arriver. Moi, je me suis
fixé une règle, c'est de ne jamais
rencontrer un homme politique, de ne
jamais partager une table avec lui. De
qui parles-tu ? [rires]
Je respecte le off.
Je pense que un déjeuner, c'est un cadre
professionnel. Déjeuner, c'est naturel.
On déjeûne avec des confrères. C'est ce
qu'on appelle les déjeuner en ville. Ça
ne sous-entend pas autre chose qu'un
rapport professionnel.
Dîner, par exemple, c'est bête. Le dîn
le dîner, c'est une autre histoire. Le
dîner. Le dîner,
c'est plus convivial. Le dîner, ça va un
peu au-delà. Moi, je ne d pas. Voilà, je
déjeûne mais je ne d pas.
Je crois que le monsieur à côté vous
voulait poser une question. Monsieur,
vous aviez une question.
Tout à fait. Une dîner.
C'était le monsieur en fait.
Je lui donne tout de suite le micro.
Est-ce que vous avez une réaction
concernant le dîner du siècle ? Les
cercles de pouvoir comme le Bildelberg,
notre communauté nous en parle souvent.
C'est pas ça pas il y a pas de très du
tout la différence. Donc monsieur
la connivance entre journaliste et et
cerc de pouvoir pas du tout.
Non mais là monsieur voulait parler
avant vous
c'est la question qui dérange ou pas du
tout ?
Pas du tout. Aucune question dérange
mais
on vous écoute sur la réponse ?
C'est pas une mauvaise question.
J'ai pas compris la question en fait.
Alors il y a des problèmes de
compréhension chez les journalistes.
Oui c'est les le dîner du siècle le
cercle des Bildelberg ça vous parle un
peu ou pas ? Oui mais là vous Oui,
parlez autrement monsieur. Là c'est pas
voulez voulez que je vous parle comment
?
Ben normalement normalement poser une
question
poser une question
non
ma question était très simple. Vous êtes
sur les rapports des des journalistes au
cercle
ce qui dérange ce qui dérange c'est un
peu autre chose je crois moi de mon
point de vue hein tout.
Oui je je vais vous dire je vous l'ai
dit déjà tout à l'heure
c'estàdire
c'est que ici il y a des gens qui sont
des auditeurs, des téléspectateurs.
Voilà vous vous êtes un journaliste
professionnel.
Non non on n'est pas journaliste. Pas du
tout. Vous avez un point de vue.
Vous avez un point de vue, c'est votre
droit.
C'est l'internet qui vous dérange ?
Non, vous avez un point de vue, c'est
votre droit. C'est votre droit le plus
absolu.
Quel est mon point de vue dans ma
question ?
On est tous des pourris. Voilà. Donc
bon. Alors maintenant, moi le siècle, je
vais vous dire, moi j'en fais pas
partie, je m'en fous. Voilà.
Voilà. Même réponse.
Les gens savent pas ce que c'est.
Nous, notre communauté 1700 abonnés le
savent.
C'est c'est bien le problème, c'est
qu'il parle d'une chose qui est réservée
à des élites. Moi je ne sais pas ce que
c'est. J'ai entendu parler. Je n'ai
jamais été dans ce genre de dîner. Donc
c'est pour ça que ça n'a rien à voir
avec le
Alors moi je dis un mot brièvement et
sans esprit polémique. Puis monsieur, on
vous donne la parole. Moi je suis au
siècle donc alors là pour le coup je
connais bien.
Ah bah c'est c'est dommage que ça soit
coupé là.
Ah bah nous on réserve ça pour le petit
Noël de nos abonnés.
Ah voilà c'était un teasing.
C'est un teasing. Qu'est-ce que tu en
penses ? Parce que là, jusque là, on est
dans le on est dans le Pierre Carles.
On est dans le Pierre Carl.
Bah ouais, on on a l'impression d'être
un peu manipulé. On attend la réponse de
Pu Jadas. Je veux dire le puisque lui il
est, c'est ce que je te disais, il est
au dîner du siècle. Donc voilà. Mais
alors attend Noël hein.
Faut attendre Noël.
Ouais, c'est le le calendrier de
l'avant. Le le il dit il dit juste avant
il va pas dîner avec les politiques.
Ouais. Ben il a juste oublié le dîner du
siècle. Ouais. Bah oui. Qu'est-ce que je
te dise ?
C'est normal dans un festival de
journalisme où il y a des oublis comme
ça ? Bah je je j'attends de savoir ce
qu'il ce qu'il dit aprè
sensiblement la même chose que toi mais
avec un petit peu plus de de il dit il
dit il dit oh mais c'est rien du tout
c'est un club du 3e âge et
voilà c'est ça
il se passe rien
non non je pense pas du tout je pense
que je pense que si tu veux euh aller
sur tous ces trucs que tu dis sur la
conivance et cetera, le ou que que dit
tout le monde je veux dire moi ça ne me
choque pas que des journalistes
fréquentent des gens de pouvoir. Je veux
dire, il cherche des infos. Alors après,
il faut pas qu'il se cantonne aux gens
de pouvoir. Faut pas qu'il y ait que des
gens de pouvoir. On revient à ce que je
te disais sur les sur Berlin 33 si tu
veux. Un des problèmes, c'est que ils
étaient totalement enfermés
dans les dans les milieux nazis et
qu'ils ont jamais cherché véritablement
en sortir, qu' voulaient pas en sortir.
Bon al registre dans un dans un système
très très différent, c'est encore ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui. Ça me choque pas.
Ce qui me choque, c'est que quand tu as
une info, tu la gardes pour toi. Ce qui
me choque, c'est le off. Je veux dire,
je je n'ai jamais supporté le off. J'ai
je je suis fait de telle manière, si tu
veux, que j'ai jamais supporté de savoir
quelque chose et de pas avoir le droit
de le dire. Et c'est je pense que c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui a fait que je me
suis indésirable dans un certain nombre
d'endroits, si tu veux. À partir du
moment où je sais un truc, je considère
que mon boulot, c'est de le dire. à
partir du moment où c'est vérifié, tout
ce que tu veux. Voilà,
les petits dîners, s'il y a du off,
c'est pas pour toi.
Mais non, je veux dire le le mais c'est
pour ça que j'ai jamais pu faire de
journalisme politique si tu veux. Quand
quand j'étais quand j'étais au monde en
fait, j'étais au service des des grands
reportages, tu vois. Ça s'appelle le
service des infogênés, c'est le service
des reporters. C'est ce que tu envoies
sur tous les coups un peu chauds quand
quand aucun journaliste installé en
cravat ne veut y aller. Euh
et j'ai il m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
de bosser avec le service politique du
journal. Ils m'ont envoyé euh ils m'ont
envoyé dans les coulisses de l'assemblée
par exemple
ou où ou justement dans des déjeunés où
les les journalistes en titre ne
pouvaient pas aller parce qu'ils en
avaient un autre ce jour-là et tout.
Mais si tu veux, je j'ai j'étais
toujours très mal à l'aise de pas avoir
le droit d'écrire ce que j'avais appris.
Et il m'est arrivé deux trois fois, il
m'est arrivé euh [rires]
de
mes brèves incursions dans le dans le
monde politique sont toujours terminé en
catastrophe parce que euh je j'écrivais
ce que j'avais appris. J'ai alors dans
j'ai couvert par exemple la guerre du
golf en 91, le l'armée française au Kit
et cetera. Euh j'ai donné voilà, c'est
un truc rigolo et ça m'est toujours ça
m'est toujours resté. Donc la guerre du
golf en 91, tu veux on est accrédité
auprès du de de l'armée française, du
ministère de la défense et tout. Et
avant l'offensive terrestre pour libérer
Cit City, on est resté trois 3 semaines
à Riad. toute la colonie journalistique
française et resté 3 semaines à Rian en
Arabie Saoudite où était l'armée
française. Et alors comme on s'emmerdait
à mort et qu'on savait pas quoi écrire
si tu veux, on a on a fait le siège de
du ministère de la défense pour avoir le
droit d'interviewer les pilotes français
qui étaient qui étaient stationnés à
proximité, les pilotes de Mirage. Bon,
donc au bout de de 10 jours où on
tpanise les militaires, ils nous disent
"OK, vous allez pouvoir prendre un café
avec les pilotes".
Euh donc on arrive on arrive aux messes
des des pilotes français. Euh on était
deux trois journalistes, il y avait un
pool, on était deux trois journalistes,
tu veux et on est stupéfait. Je veux
dire, les les pilotes français
commencent à dinguer leurs avions, à
dzinguer leur mirages, à expliquer que
leur mirages perdent de leur boulons,
que c'est des modèles d' ans, que par
rapport au tornado anglais, ils ont eu
ils ont la honte de leur vie et cetera.
Je veux dire, j'avais jamais entendu ça
à la télé. J'avais jamais lu dans le
journal que les pilotes français
trouvait que leur mirage était des des
vieilles boues si tu veux. Alors, je je
gratte, je gratte, je gratte, je gratte.
Euh [grognement]
et évidemment,
j'envoie le le j'envoie le papier de ma
vie au monde euh les les les pilotes
français très sévères sur leur mirage et
cetera. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Il
s'est passé que le le le rubricard
militaire du journal, c'està-dire le
gars qui en titre était chargé de suivre
l'armée, donc qui connaissait tous
l'état major et les connaissait tous les
généraux de l'étatmajor par leur prénoms
et les prénoms de leurs enfants et de
leurs petits enfants si tu veux à sauter
au plafond euh et à dire "On peut pas
publier ça, on peut pas publier ça."
Donc la rédaction en chef extrêmement
embarrassé à l'époque si tu veux parce
qu'il pouvait quand même pas censurer le
papier, la rédaction en chef a supprimé
la moitié du papier. Bon, mais on a on a
quand même laissé une bonne moitié, ce
qui a été suffisant pour que le
lendemain matin, si tu veux, quand le
journal est paru, l'état major fasse un
démenti sur le thème, mais pas du tout,
mais les les pilotes français sont très
fiers de voler de voler sur leur mirage
et et les mirages vont très bien. Bon
voilà, je c'est la raison qui
t'explique, si tu veux, que j'ai j'ai
jamais réussié juste après ou pas du
tout ?
Non, j'ai pas démissionné ce que je veux
c'était une expérience. J'allais pas
démissionner pour ça, c'était une
expérience. Puis je trou je trouvais
j'avais quand même réussi à en sauver la
moitié si tu veux.
La charte Dominique ça te parle
? Alors vas-y.
Non les droit de du journalisme.
Je connais pas. Oui je connais pas bien.
J'ai
non plus. Tu fais tu fais de l'amnésie
sélective ou
Non ? Non mais par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'elle prescrit ?
Bah je sais pas c'est toi c'est ton
boulot ou
B. Non mais tu en parles. Ça donne que
tu l'
Je te pose une je te pose juste une
question. Tu l'as lu ou pas ?
Ah bah plus d'une fois. Ouais. Bah
alors, je te laisser je te laisserai
non mais la ch domque en soi, je veux
dire, non, ça me ça me je sais pas, ça
me dit pas grand-chose mais je sais pas.
Est-ce que tu connais un peu est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres chartes de
l'équivalent du serment d'Hippocrate
pour le journalisme ?
Euh je
il y a il y a des il y a des trucs si tu
veux de bon sens. Il y a des trucs de
bon sens, c'est que tu l'as lu la chair
de Munique ?
Oui, j'ai dû la lire, je veux dire
franchement, j'ai dû la lire il y a très
longtemps. Je sais plus très bien ce
qu'il y a dedans. Euh voilà. Donc mais
après, si tu veux le dans dans la
pratique journalistique, il y a a y a
des il y a des trucs de bon sens, c'est
que effectivement tu ne tu bidonnes pas
une information.
Alors après, il y a des il y a des
choses plus plus limites. Par exemple,
l'usurpation d'identité euh
enquêter sous faon
le le alors l'enquête sous faenon ou la
caméra cachée ou euh enfin tous ces tous
ces toutes ces pratiques qui sont en
effet un peu limite si tu veux et sur
lesquelles moi personnellement j'ai du
mal à me à me faire une opinion très
précise et personnelle si tu veux. par
exemple la caméra cachée.
Euh je trouve qu'il y a des je trouve
qu'il y a des circonstances où c'est
justifié, il y a des circonstances où
c'est pas justifié. C'est juste pour
faire des des belles images parce que
les images en caméra cachée, ça fait
vraiment le truc on vous révèle un
machin que personne voulait et des fois
ça des fois juste ça n'en vaut pas la
peine. Euh enquêter sous faux nom, c'est
pareil. Je pense qu'il peut y avoir des
il peut y avoir des des des
circonstances dans lesquelles c'est
justifié, c'est nécessaire. Mais si tu
veux ce que je pense c'est que le
principal c'est que tu dises toujours à
ton lecteur quand tu es journaliste ou à
ton téléspectateur voilà comment j'ai
travaillé. J'ai travaillé sous faux nom.
J'ai travaillé en caméra cachée et voilà
pourquoi je l'ai fait. À partir du
moment où le pacte entre le le
journaliste et son public, il est à peu
près clair si tu veux, je considère
qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de véritable
il y a pas de véritable interdit. C'est
le dans un autre domaine, on dit entre
adultes consentant tout est permis. Euh
je pense qu'à partir du moment où le le
pacte d'information est sur la table, si
tu veux, je suis pas choqué par
grand-chose.
La liberté de la presse en France, ça a
régressé. Euh ça fait quoi ça ? Ça a
progressé ? Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Bah il y a la il y a le comme diraient
nos camarades marxistes, il y a la
liberté formelle et la liberté réelle.
Euh
quand tu commences à bouger que tu vois
si tes chaînes font du bruit, c'est ça
par exemple. Non mais si tu veux le le
en gros en France aujourd'hui d'un point
de vue légal la presse écrit à peu près
ce qu'elle veut. Enfin il y a une loi il
y a des lois sur la diffamation
qui sont extrêmement libérales pour les
journalistes. Il faut le dire. Je veux
dire qui qu'il est qu'il les laisse. Et
le secret des affaires.
Alors le secret des affaires, faut être
très vigilant. Le Non, non, mais je veux
dire le le les différentes lois si tu
veux qui qui qui sont euh en préparation
ou qui ou qui les différentes moutures
de de loi visant à restreindre les les
le champ des journalismes des
journalistes d'investigation au nom du
secret des affaires,
faut être très vigilant. Ce qui veut pas
dire que le secret des affaires n'existe
pas. Ça existe le secret des affaires.
Je veux dire, il y a des il y a des il y
a des boîtes effectivement qui euh euh
détiennent des brevets et qui ont pas
envie que ces brevets
tombent dans les mains de leurs
concurrents. Le le secret du business,
ça existe. Il faut
comme en Australie quand il y a un
journaliste qui dit voilà il y a le
gouvernement australien qui est en train
de faire des choses pas très claires
dans une île où il y a du gaz, où il y a
du pétrole qui se fait [__] en toule,
c'est normal.
Non mais non mais ça n'a rien à voir. Là
on parle, tu me parlais du secret des
affaires. Là maintenant tu me parles du
gouvernement australien. Donc tu
c'est pas des affaires, c'est pas du
business, il y a rien à voir. OK,
j'en sais rien. Je sais pas, je connais
pas l'affaire dont tu parles mais c'est
c'est le le gouvernement australien,
c'est pas une c'est pas une
multinationale.
Antoine Deltour, non ?
Oui, très bien. Formidable. Antoine
Deltour. Voilà ce qui ce qui alors ce
qu'il a fait était parfaitement
justifié.
Je trouve absolument scandaleux
qu'il ait été poursuivi. Je suis très
heureux qu'il a été acquitté. Voilà.
Non, mais si tu veux le je pense que
quand tu quand tu quand tu enquêtes sur
l'évasion fiscale, si tu veux, tu ne tu
n'enquêtes pas sur le secret des
affaires, tu enquêtes sur l'évasion
fiscale. Alors après, pour déterminer
la limite entre le disciple et le enfin
le légitime et le pas légitime, il y a
un critère aussi assez simple, c'est
l'intérêt public.
Euh je veux dire quand tu cherches ta
boussole si tu veux quand tu quand tu
entre ce que tu peux dire et ce que tu
peux pas dire, il y a un critère assez
simple, c'est l'intérêt public. Est-ce
que ce que je vais révéler est d'intérêt
public ?
Est-ce que l'autocensure peut être
salvateur ?
Non mais le est-ce que quoi
l'autocensure peut être salvateur ?
Non mais attends, on va poser la
question comme ça. Comment tu veux je te
réponde oui. Non mais comment tu C'est
quoi ton arrière-pensée quand tu me
demandes si l'autocensure je me fais la
voc du diable ? Est-ce que l'autocensure
peut être salvatrice ? Un cas, cite-moi
un cas. Voilà,
un cas. Un cas. Imagine-toi, tu as un
journaliste qui apprend qu' il y a une
météorite qui va tomber sur la terre.
D'accord.
Mettons,
mettons,
mettons un gros.
Mettons mettons mettons. Il y a des
météorites, elles vont tomber sur la
terre.
Voilà. Voilà. Et il va y avoir une
déstabilisation de tout le monde.
Est-ce que tu le gardes ? Tu le gardes
pas ? Qu'est-ce que tu en fais ?
Écoute, je vais te surprendre, je ne me
suis jamais posé cette question. Je te
jure que je vais me la poser et si tu
veux, tu me réinviteras.
[rires]
On va passer à deux trois questions
internet euh d'ailleurs qui ne sont même
pas des questions. Alors
Chomskiinterrogation,
on l'a reçu R sur Image. Hm
hm.
Euh je l'ai interviewé en anglais.
J'étais assez fier d'avoir réussi à
faire une heure en interviewant Jste en
anglais.
Donc on va continuer l'interview en
Ah si tu veux.
Go ahead.
Ouais if you want. Euh je [rires] suis
pas sûr que ce soit la meilleure chose.
[grognement]
Euh non, c'est très intéressant ce qu'il
dit Chomski. Qu'est-ce que tu veux que
je te dise ? C'est c'est quelqu'un qui a
qui a totalement bouleversé la pensée
sur les médias, la pensée enfin je veux
dire le la la pensée sur la fabrication
du consensus. Enfin, je veux dire moi il
m'a énormément éclairé. Oui.
Tu dit qu'il part chez Rouatou pour
l'interrogation. Oui.
Bah j'ai comment dire euh j'ai j'ai
trouvé euh désolant si tu veux qu'il y
ait pas une chaîne française qui
récupère ta DI quand son émission a été
supprimée. De la même manière que j'ai
trouvé désolant qu'il y a pas une chaîne
française qui récupère arrêt sur image.
Euh après le voilà de je pense qu'il est
parfaitement conscient que il va être le
le la libe de de Russia Today. Euh et
après j'attends de voir les son émission
en fait tu sais je c'est enf tuis il y a
les principes
il y a est-ce que c'est bien que TI
parte chez Russia Today j'en sais rien
ça le regarde. Et après il y a quelle
émission il va faire sur Russia Today.
Donc j'attends de voir l'émission qu'il
va faire. J'attends de voir si on va
apprendre des choses dans son émission.
J'attends de voir s'il va inviter des
gens qui nous sont invités nulle part et
qui ont des choses extrêmement
intéressantes à dire. J'en sais rien.
Le point de vue sur les journaux comme
Fakir ou lundi matin.
Oui.
Question d'internet.
Euh Fakir, je trouve ça sympa. Je trouve
ça sympa. Je trouve que les papiers sont
parfois un peu longs. Il ils ont fait
des ils ont fait du très très bon
travail sur les les accidents du travail
et notamment sur une histoire d'accident
du travail à à Amien qui avait été très
peu couverte par la presse
traditionnelle. Là, ils ont ils ont
vraiment fait du très bon travail.
Voilà. Non, c'est bien. Enfin, voilà.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux je te dise ?
Voilà. Et l'autre c'est lundi matin. Je
trouve c'est bien écrit.
C'est bien écrit. Je suis sensible à la
qualité d'écriture.
Est-ce que il y a des invités que tu te
refuses dans arrêt sur image ?
Plein.
Lesquels ?
Bah ceux qui m'intéressent pas.
Est-ce que tu as une liste noire de gens
que t'inviter pas ?
Longue ?
Longue.
Non mais non mais j'ai pas une liste
noire de gens que je n'inviterai pas.
J'ai une liste j'ai une liste longue de
de gens que j'ai pas envie d'inviter.
Déjà les hommes politiques si tu veux.
On on a non mais on a totalement au
début on a invité les hommes politiques
euh et puis on a on a totalement arrêté
euh on a totalement arrêté parce que si
tu veux je trouve enfin je veux dire
non mais je trouve que j'ai pas envie de
si tu veux en tant qu'interviewur
j'ai pas envie de faire de l'interview
de posture si tu vois ce que je veux
dire j'ai pas envie de de j'ai je trouve
je trouve ça intéressant d'interroger
quelqu'un
dans le
qui vient là pour te débiter ce qu'il a
déjà dit partout tout et ce qu'il dira
ensuite dans tous les dans toutes les
émissions où il ira après la tienne. Tu
vois, ça m'intéresse pas.
Est-ce que tu trouves qu'il y a au 21e
siècle, est-ce qu'il y a des sujets ?
Est-ce qu'il y a les journalistes font
l'impasse sur certains sujets ?
Bien sûr.
Lesquels ?
Les sujets emmerdants.
Lesquels ? Il y a pas de je pense qu'il
y a pas de sujet interdit si tu veux euh
contrairement à la mythologie de "Il y a
des sujets euh il y a des sujets
interdits." Non, il y a pas de sujet euh
il y a pas de sujets interdits. Il y a
des sujets emmerdants. Il y a des sujets
en Il y a des sujets emmerdants
pour sa vie professionnelle pour
Non non mais non mais non. Le le le le
grand patron, c'est pas le directeur qui
téléphone et qui censure. Le grand
patron, c'est l'audience.
[rires] L'audience. Donc les sujets dont
les les rédactions euh imaginent que
qu'ils ne vont pas faire d'audience, si
tu veux, ils ne les traitent pas. Alors,
je vais te donner un exemple. Euh
l'autre l'autre jour, il y a des
habitants de de la commune de Leblanc
dans l'Indre 36 euh [grognement]
qui occupaient leur maternité parce que
cette maternité doit fermer.
Et selon le ministère de la santé, si tu
veux, cette maternité doit fermer.
C'est-à-dire que les femmes de cette
ville euh vont devoir pour accoucher
aller faire 1h et3 de voiture pour aller
pour aller accoucher à Orléan ou à
Châurou ou dans une troisième ville, je
sais plus laquelle euh parce que leur
maternité va fermer. Le ministère de la
santé dit "C'est pas du tout une
question d'argent, ça n'a rien à voir,
c'est pas du tout une question de
rationalisation de l'hôpital et cetera.
C'est parce que cette cette maternité
est insécure. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu
des problèmes de sécurité dans cette
maternité. Bon, le l'autre jour un
matin, je voulais faire ma c'était le
matin où les gendarmes ont évacué les
femmes qui occupaient cette maternité si
tu veux. J'ai je dis tiens, je vais
faire ma chronique là-dessus, ma
chronique du matin 9h15, c'est
intéressant. Je vais essayer de voir ce
qui s'est dit et cetera. Alors, j'ai
déjà il y a très peu de je
papiers si tu veux. Il y a très peu de
papiers. Je veux dire, il y a des
papiers quand Mélenchon il va ou il y a
des papiers quand Benoît Amont il va
parce que là ça devient un événement
politique si Mélenchon il va ou si
Benoît mon il va mais si tu veux une
maternité qui ferme dans un bled de
l'Indre les médias nationaux s'en
foutent. Tu vois tu me parlais de sujet
interdit voilà sujet interdit parce que
présumé emmerdant voilà la fermeture de
la maternité de l'Indre.
J'étais décidé, si tu veux, aller au
bout du truc et à essayer de savoir si
cette maternité fermait vraiment parce
qu'il il y avait eu des problèmes de
sécurité. Bon, alors que le conflit dure
depuis des mois et des mois, j'ai pas
trouvé un seul papier d'enquête de
journalistes local ou national pour
essayer de savoir pourquoi fermer cette
maternité. C'est c'est important si tu
veux. C'est important. Je veux dire le
tu vois le jugement qu'on porte sur
Macron, les les problèmes de l'hôpital,
tout le monde va te parler des problèmes
de l'hôpital en général avec des des
grands arguments d'un côté, de l'autre
et cetera, mais personne ne s'intéresse
au détail, personne ne s'intéresse au
cas concret. Le journalisme français, il
crève de ça. Il crèvent que dans toutes
les redac
ou très peu, enfin j'exagère parce que
ça arrive toujours, mais si tu veux là
sur le cas précis, c'était pas arrivé.
On on va pas dégager quelqu'un, ça
prendrait pas très longtemps, je pense.
Ça prend 3 jours, 4 jours, 3 jours ou 4
jours pour essayer de savoir pourquoi
une maternité. Voilà voilà les le genre
de truc qui mettent en en rogne et c'est
pour répondre à tes questions sur les
les sujets interdits.
Euh quelle solution pour remettre
On arrête si tu veux hein. Si si tu
t'emmerdes, on arrête.
Non, j'ai pas encore eu de faire pipi
encore. Ça va,
ça va.
Euh quelle solution pour remédier euh
concernant tout ce qui est euh
propagande, conspi, fake news, question
d'internet ?
Euh je pense que c'est très dur euh le
je pense que c'est très dur le
je veux dire c'est
au journalisme de s'y attaquer. Euh Oui.
Oui. Et je pense que c'est très dur si
tu veux les les les gens qui pensent que
[soupir]
euh les gens qui pensent qu'un Boeing
n'est pas tombé sur le Pentagone le 11
septembre 2001 si tu veux. Je sais pas
très bien comment les aborder ces
gens-là.
Oui, c'est très compliqué.
Est-ce que tu les connais ?
Oui. Alors, je vais te dire,
est-ce que tu les as infiltré ?
Non, je les ai pas infiltré parce que
moi la différence de Seview, je pratique
pas le l'infiltration si tu veux. Je je
parle sous mon nom et je et pas sous
pseudo. Mais alors quand j'étais à
France 5, si tu veux, par exemple, je
faisais sur image à France 5, j'ai
toujours refusé de d'inviter Thierry
Messens. Je me ai dit, on va pas donner
la parole à ce mec qui pense que un
Boeing ne s'est pas écrasé sur le
Pentagone.
Euh quand je me suis retrouvé sur
internet et c'est alors et c'était avant
internet, c'est-à-dire c'était à une
époque où le système médiatique avait à
peu près les moyens euh d'accéder à
l'espace, d'empêcher d'accéder à
l'espace public un mec qui disait que il
y avait pas de Boeing sur le Pentagone.
Tu vois ? Bon, depuis internet, les les
médias traditionnels n'ont plus ces
moyens là. Si tu veux le le le mec qui
dit que il y a pas eu de Boeing sur le
Pentagone, il fait sa vidéo, il fait ses
il crée son compte Twitter. Je veux
dire, tu as aux États-Unis, tuas tuas tu
as un conspirationniste ultra connu,
comment
il s'appelle ?
Euh Jones et son prénom son son prénom
Mchap mais voilà, je sais plus quoi. Oh,
enfin le nom de famille c'est Jones. euh
qui non seulement est ultra connu, ultra
puissant, qui a une énorme
Alex Jones, celui qui s'est fait Alex
Jones, celui qui s'est fait retirer son
compte Twitter, sa chaîne YouTube.
Voilà, c'est lui Alace Jones euh à qui
Trump a donné une interview pendant la
campagne et cetera. Donc ça, c'est les
États-Unis, la France. Bon, donc la
question c'est comment euh
nous journalistes
professionnels si tu veux on se
positionne par rapport à ça. Bon alors
depuis qu'on est sur internet, j'ai j'ai
invité une fois sur le plateau, ce que
je me suis dit après tout, il y a pas de
raison de pas le faire, j'ai invité une
fois un représentant de Reopen 911.
Bon, je pense pas que ça ait donné une
émission géniale si tu veux, mais euh et
puis si j'ai pas récidivé, c'est parce
que j'ai pas forcément trouvé le truc
génial pour traiter ce genre de pour
traiter ce genre de chos. Mais je pense
que on va dire en tout cas dans un
dispositif de plateau comme celui où on
est là si tu veux la réfutation
horrifiée du journaliste face à face à
Reopen 91. Mais vous rendez compte de ce
que vous dites ? Mais c'est incroyable,
mais c'est scandaleux, mais comment
pouvez-vous ? Et cetera. Je pense que ça
marche pas. Ça ça renforce
mais ça renforce le ça renforce le mec
puisque il a en face de lui un
journaliste plus ou moins encarté et
donc si tu veux ça ça le fait que les
journalistes encartés démentent la la
version conspirationniste, ça quelque
part ça la renforce. Vous voyez voilà,
ils sont tous de mèches pour cacher la
vérité et cetera. Je pense que le bon la
bonne façon de faire en tout cas la
moins mauvaise euh c'est de pousser euh
ces gens-là au bout de leur logique si
tu veux. Alors très bien, il y a pas eu
de Boeing sur le Pentagone, admettons.
Mais alors, il y a quand même un Boeing
qui a décollé à un moment. Il est passé
où ? Si si c'est s'il s'est pas écrasé
sur le Pentagone, il est passé où ? On a
trouvé une carcasse quelque part.
D'accord. Alors, il a été enlevé dans un
il a été il été envoyé dans un pays
tiers ou enf tu vois le
le mais tu sais le le c'est c'est
marrant parce que à propos de
conspirationnisme,
j'ai j'ai un souvenir très drôle pour te
montrer que ça ça n'épargne personne.
Quand j'étais quand à Rimage j'étais
encore sur France 5, on avait reçu
Jean-Jacques Bourdin.
C'était on va dire c'était 2006 2007 et
cetera.
Et Jean-Jacques Bourdin avait lancé un
truc sur sa sur sa radio sur RMC
[grognement] et il avait lancer l'idée
que il y avait en France 6 sous-marins
nucléaires officiels mais qu'il pouvait
y en avoir un 7e que personne ne
connaissait si tu veux.
et
et Jean-Jacques Bourdin était venu sur
le plateau chez nous, je sais plus quoi,
on avait fait un sujet sur les
sous-marins, un reportage sur les
sous-marins et et je je vois mon bourdin
sur le plateau qui qui avait pas l'air
d'être sûr qu'il y avait pas un 7e
sous-marin nucléaire clandestin.
Si tu veux, tu c'est pour te dire que
euh bon et donc je poser les questions
de base. Jean-Jacques Bourdin, c'est un
7e, c'est si un 7e sous-marin, il est
servi par des sous-mariniers. Donc ces
gens-là, ils sont bien payés, ils sont
secrets défenses
dans Donc alors ils sont secrets
défense, d'accord, mais il faut les
payer. Donc je veux dire, il y a un
budget pour payer ce 7e sous-marin. Donc
ce budget, s'il est pas inscrit au
budget officiel de la défense, si tu
veux, où ça passe ? Enfin voilà, si tu
veux le j'avais essayé de le pousser
jusqu'au bout de cette logique de
l'existence du 7e sous-marin clandestin
et à la suite de quoi, il a abandonné la
assez vite la thèse du 7e sous-marin
clandestin si tu veux. Je pense que la
bonne façon de faire
par rapport à ces par rapport au conspis
qui soit qui soit internaute de base ou
qui s'appelle Jean-Jacques Bourdin,
c'est ça [soupir]
que une propagande sur le système
financier en disant voilà pour nous
le capitalisme c'est le meilleur système
et que tous les journalistes tous les
journalistes économiques reprennent ça
en fanfare. Est-ce que c'est normal, pas
normal ? Est-ce qu'on doit ouvrir un
troisème chemin à d'autres opinions ou
B ? Non, c'est pas normal. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ? Non, c'est pas normal. Je pense
que alors c'est explicable parce que là
pour le coup si tu veux
ça peut très facilement s'expliquer par
le le système d'actionnariat de la de la
presse française aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que la les médias français
aujourd'hui soit ils appartiennent à
l'État euh soit ils appartiennent à
Arnaud Boloré et toute la bande que tu
que tu connais bien. Euh et donc non
mais si tu veux enfin que tu connais
bien de de réputation
je je sais bien que nous ne sommes pas
chez Boloré et chez Arnaud ici.
[grognement]
Pas encore.
Va savoir, [soupir]
va savoir un jour.
Attention, on a l'impression de voir
Jean-Jacques Bourdin là.
Ah non non non. Mais par exemple euh je
crois que les les locaux appartiennent à
une boîte de prod.
Ben peut-être bien. Ouais.
Tu es pas sûr ?
On n pas sûr.
Tu es pas sûr ? Mais alors ça appartient
à qui ? Ça
une boîte de prod.
Ça appartient à une boîte de prod, on
est d'accord. Bon et comme je suis un
peu curieux, j'ai je me suis renseigné
un peu avant de venir ici, j'ai vu que
cette boîte de prod travaille pour des
grandes boîtes comme LVMH par exemple.
Ouais. Donc pour Bernard Arnaud donc
s'il y avait des conspis qui
s'intéressaient à Syerview, il pourrait
dire Syerview, oui mais LVMH Arnaud et
cetera. Bon bref, fin de la parenthèse
rigolote, je je sais bien que vous
n'avez rien à voir à Syerview avec
Bernard Arnaud. C'est c'est sur
tu confirmes qu'on est dans une cave ?
Absolument. Mais la cave est une boîte
de prod qui travaille aussi pour pour
LVMH, pour Dior tout ça. Enfin c'est sur
le site he, c'est pas secret. Euh c'est
je veux dire j'ai rien j'ai pas fait
d'infiltration. Euh c'était quoi ta
question ? le [rires]
capitalisme bah oui non voilà je veux
dire on a une presse qui appartient à
des capitalistes donc elle défend le
capitalisme. Oui. Qu'est-ce tu veux que
je te dise ?
Voilà mais oui mais oui. Non c'est pas
bien. Je veux dire
changer les choses. On fait comment pour
changer les choses ?
On crée des médias indépendants financés
par leurs abonnés monsieur.
Et donc c'est tu nous envoies la perche.
On on a beaucoup de podcasters qui nous
écoutent. Oui,
n'oubliez pas de nous financer sur Tipi,
c'est des dons. N'hésitez pas,
faites-vous plaisir, ça nous rendra
encore plus fort et plus indépendant.
Et n'hésitez pas, si je peux me
permettre,
à souscrire des abonnements sur Arrê sur
image.
Et
combien ça coûte ?
Alors, ça coûte 45 € par an, par an et 4
€ par mois. Donc, il y a le choix entre
la bonne donc c'est c'est que dalle si
tu veux. C'est que dalle, mais il y a
encore des gens qui nous disent "C'est
trop cher." Donc c'est vrai qu'on on a
aussi euh à 22 € maintenant par euh par
an un abon
pour les étudiants et les chômeurs,
un abonnement euh précaire étudiant et
chômeur. Et euh et alors c'est marrant
parce qu'on a, je veux dire euh là, on
est en train de faire une petite
campagne de de fin d'année et on a on a
plein de gens qui nous disent "J'adore
ce que vous faites mais euh j'ai pas le
temps de tout lire, vos tous vos
papiers, de regarder toutes vos
émissions et tout dont j'ai pas le
temps."
Donc je profite de mon interview à c
interview pour dire à tous ces gens mais
vous pouvez nous soutenir sans nous lire
et sans nous regarder c'est possible.
Vous vous pouvez nous faire un don sur
une plateforme qui s'appelle j'aime
l'info euh qui est justement faite pour
ça euh et qui sera un don déductible à
hauteur de 66 % du revenu intérêt
général. C'est ça
absolument du revenu imposable de 2018.
Question d'internet la collaboration
Facebook gouvernement pour lutter contre
la haine sur les réseaux sociaux.
Oui. Alors ça ça a été annoncé
aujourd'hui mais moi je suis pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas regardé en détail. Je pas
je connais pas les modalités.
C'est terrible chez toi disons faut
avoir un avis sur tout quoi. J'ai pas
encore d'avis. Je sais pas j'ai pas
regardé j'étais j'ai pr la toute la
toute c'est c'est une c'est une
Si tu as pas d'avis que tu es pas au
courant. Tu dis juste que tu es pas au
courant et que tu as pas d'avis tout de
suite. C'est ce que je viens de dire.
Parfait.
Voilà. Non mais j'explique hein
euh
que j'étais en train de préparer mon
interview.
Ça c'est une question de ta génération.
Ça y est. Ah le scude. [rires] C'est pas
un scude.
Le scud un exocè peut-être qui
aujourd'hui finance les nouveaux Denis
Robert et comment ?
Bah
on en a parlé un peu. On a eu on a on a
on a abordé la question avec le
Disclose
avec Disclose. Voilà. Je pense que je
pense que les j'espère que les les
nouveaux les nouveaux dener si tu veux
qu'il seront plus financés par Canal
Plus, ça c'est sûr, et qui seront plus
puis [rires]
et seront seront vont trouver des
modèles du genre d'close.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Oh là là, mais c'est horrible ce ce
genre de
euh qu'est-ce que tu veux je te dise un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Croyez-y les gars et les filles, mais
les jeunes générations quoi de de en
général ou les jeunes générations de
journalistes ?
Choisis les J'ai un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, c'est ne renoncer
jamais à poser des questions connes.
Voilà ce que j'ai ce que j'ai appris de
mes parents et ce que j'ai transmis à
mes enfants, j'espère.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller ?
Euh
alors, est-ce que j'ai trois livres à
conseiller ? Écoute, je sais pas si je
les conseille. Euh en ce moment, il se
trouve que je suis en train de alors
c'est j'ai des c'est pas des nouveautés
hein. Je suis en train de lire en ce
moment les mémoires de Churchill.
Génial, génial. La la la guerre vue de
l'intérieur, ses rendez-vous avec
Roosevelt, ses rendez-vous avec Staline.
Formidable.
Et en même temps
et en même temps ce qui nous ce qui nous
ramène à ce qui nous ramène à mon livre
et en même temps je suis terrifié
de voir à quel point la persécution des
juifs est absente totalement de son
champ de vision. J'ai pas encore fini
mais il y a pas un mot. Je veux dire
voilà.
Alors ça ça fait un Alors il y en a un
après il y a des grands classiques. Je
vais m'en sortir avec les grands
classiques si tu veux. Les Je pense que
il y a un livre qui ne se qui ne se
démode pas et qui ne se démodera jamais
c'est l'étrange des défites de Mark
Block. Euh on parlait de journalisme.
Mark Block est pas journaliste. Il est
il est historien. Euh et pourtant il à
chaud si tu veux immédiatement après la
débat le 40, il va te te te
passer au scanner les raisons de la
débat le de 40. Tout le monde y passe.
Les ouvriers, les patrons, les élites,
les généraux, les intellectuels.
Et c'est un c'est un livre d'une
modernité incroyable qui ne qui je veux
dire qui qui t'aide à comprendre.
D'abord, c'est c'est un reportage
formidable puisque non seulement il est
historien, mais il était il était sous
l'uniforme pendant la campagne de 40 si
tu veux. Donc il raconte son unité euh
et en même temps c'est un livre qui te
qui te qui te raconte la France quoi. La
France de 40 mais la France de 40 qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas tellement changé. Et
après voilà, après moi mon mon
livre de le livre que je reprends sans
arrêt si tu veux, c'est le c'est un
roman de c'est un recueil de poésie
d'Aragon qui s'appelle le roman inachevé
qui est qui est mon qui est mon recueil
qui est mon recueil de chevet parce que
je j'aime beaucoup Aragon.
Quand il y a des journalistes qui
finissent porte-parole du gouvernement
ou d'un gouvernement, qu'est-ce que tu
en penses ?
Que c'est leur c'est c'est leur
trajectoire. Qu'est-ce que je te dise ?
c'est c'est révélateurs de c'est
révélateurs effectivement d'un certain
esprit de de de connivance entre les
journalistes et les politiques. C'est ce
qu'on disait au début de l'émission, tu
vois. Donc voilà, ça c'est un
révélateur. Après, je veux pas les juger
personnellement, c'est leur trajectoire.
C'est voilà, c'est à un moment ils en
ont marre, c'est leur histoire.
Daniel Cinderman. Merci. Et ben merci à
toi. Mais je sais pas comment t'appeler.
Bruno
Bruno, c'est pas Camille, c'est Bruno.
Merci Bruno.
[musique]